praying in the landfill on our knees, trading old songs for new IDs. Are we warm ghosts in the machine? Hey, guys, this is Joel, and welcome back to the Tapreet Therapy Collective podcast. Psychotherapy on the couch, a psychohistory of American psychology. What psychology can see, what it can't, and why it has trouble telling the difference. This is part eight. I'm on vacation in Alaska, so I don't have all the bells and whistles for editing. I hope this one turns out similar to the other ones, but we'll go ahead and jump into it,
在垃圾填埋场里跪着祈祷，用旧歌换取新的身份。我们是机器里温暖的幽灵吗？嘿，大家好，我是乔尔，欢迎回到“Tapreet治疗集体”播客。沙发上的心理治疗，美国心理学的心理史。心理学能看到什么，不能看到什么，以及为什么它难以区分这两者。这是第八部分。我正在阿拉斯加度假，所以没有那些花哨的编辑设备。我希望这一期能和之前的效果差不多，但我们还是直接开始吧，
and I did want to go ahead and get these out so you all don't have to wait another month. But there is a meeting happening right now in some office building in San Francisco or Austin or one of the other usual places where engineers and venture capitalists are working out exactly when they can replace your therapist with a large language model based on AI. And they're not figuring out if they're going to do this. They're trying to figure out when they're going to do this. The technology is already good enough by the metrics that they care about that we've already talked about to produce the text that looks like therapy, the technique that is evidence-based practice. The remaining problems are regulatory.
我确实想尽快把这些内容发布出来，这样你们就不用再等一个月了。但此时此刻，在旧金山、奥斯汀或其他一些常规地点，某些办公大楼里正在召开会议，工程师和风险投资家们正在精确计算何时可以用基于人工智能的大语言模型来取代你们的治疗师。他们不是在考虑是否要这样做，而是在计算何时实施。按照他们关心的指标，以及我们之前讨论过的标准，这项技术已经足够成熟，可以生成看起来像心理治疗的文本，即所谓的循证实践。剩下的问题只是监管方面的。
They're not technical. And they're going to solve those problems. And they're going to roll out that product. And when the evidence indicts that, we'll just have to figure out what went wrong inside of this system that we're already doing as we're doing it, because that would be evidence-based. The American mental health workforce is going to be displaced, you know, in 10 years as much as we let them. And the apparatus that we've spent seven episodes tracing, the apparatus that built the DSM and captured the credentialing pipelines and engineered the cold machine version of psychotherapy across 40 years and still can't see what works and what doesn't, is going to embrace the replacement enthusiastically. Because the replacement is what the apparatus has been working towards this whole time. And the AI is not a threat to the apparatus.
它们不是技术问题。他们会解决这些问题，并推出该产品。当证据表明这一点时，我们只能在系统运行的过程中去弄清楚系统内部出了什么问题，因为那才是“循证”的。你知道，在未来10年里，美国心理健康从业者将被取代，程度取决于我们允许到什么地步。我们花了七集时间追踪的那个机构——那个构建了DSM、占领了认证渠道、在40年间设计出心理治疗的冷酷机器版本，却依然看不出什么有效、什么无效的机构——将会热情地拥抱这种替代。因为这种替代正是该机构一直以来努力的方向。人工智能对该机构构不成威胁。
The AI is the fulfillment of the apparatus. The AI is not even really the villain here. It's just the latest iteration of a system. And the apparatus has spent 40 years training the field to deliver something a large language model could produce already. You said therapy is if this than that. If you go through and you replace these things with just a flow chart that says like somebody uses at a call center. You know, when someone says this, you say that. When they say this, you say that is a cognitive distortion.
人工智能是该机构的实现。人工智能甚至算不上这里的反派。它只是一个系统的最新迭代。该机构花了40年时间训练这个领域去提供某种大语言模型已经能生成的东西。你说治疗就是“如果这样，就那样”。如果你去把这些东西替换成一个流程图，就像某人在呼叫中心使用的一样。你知道，当某人说这个，你就说那个。当他们说这个，你就说那是认知扭曲。
The interventions for this cognitive distortion are these three things. If you think therapy works like that, then why not use a large language model? And that's what's happening. And the answer that I have kind of been trying to get at this whole series that isn't I know it answer. It's a you should know it answer. And we all really, on some level, know it answer. Is that the active ingredient in psychotherapy is not trackable.
针对这种认知扭曲的干预措施就是这三件事。如果你认为治疗是这样运作的，那为什么不使用大语言模型呢？这就是正在发生的事情。而我在这整个系列中一直试图得出的答案，不是一个“我知道”的答案，而是一个“你应该知道”的答案。我们所有人，在某种程度上，都知道这个答案。那就是心理治疗的活性成分是无法追踪的。
Not metaphorically untrackable. really empirically untrackable either, but the variables that determine whether the work succeeds can't be measured en masse inside of systems that hold no humanity. The depth of a practitioner's work on themselves is an important variable, and it's one that the system doesn't want to acknowledge because, one, it's hard to track, and then two, it's expensive to produce. The sole accumulation of clinical maturity over a career that nobody measured because nobody knew how is important. And a lot of times the bad therapist, the people who are in school with them, know that they're going to be bad therapists. But the machine, the people who are supposed to be finding what makes therapy
不是隐喻意义上的无法追踪，而是实证意义上也无法追踪。决定治疗是否成功的变量，无法在没有人类情感的系统中进行大规模衡量。从业者在自身成长上所下的功夫是一个重要变量，但系统不想承认这一点，因为第一，它很难追踪；第二，它产出成本很高。一个人在职业生涯中积累的临床成熟度，因为没人知道如何衡量，所以没人去衡量，但这很重要。很多时候，糟糕的治疗师，和他们一起上学的同学，都知道他们会成为糟糕的治疗师。但机器，那些本应找出是什么让治疗
good and bad, can't see that because it means, one, it's not teachable. Two, if you pay us a lot of money, we can't just teach anyone how to do it. And then three, it might require a process that is not a formula. And that is largely what academic training programs are scared of, but they're not really the biggest problem or they don't have the most power inside of this apparatus. You know, what produces outcomes when outcomes get produced in psychotherapy, you know, the meta-analysis going back to the 70s have been saying this, it is not really one technique versus another technique. You know, every honest piece of outcomes research that has ever been done
变得好或坏的人，却看不见这一点，因为这意味着：第一，它不可传授。第二，如果你付给我们很多钱，我们不能直接教任何人怎么做。第三，它可能需要一个非公式化的过程。这在很大程度上是学术培训项目所恐惧的，但它们并不是最大的问题，或者说它们在这个机构内部并没有最大的权力。你知道，当心理治疗产生疗效时，是什么产生了疗效？你知道，追溯到70年代的荟萃分析一直在说，这并不是某种技术对比另一种技术的问题。你知道，每一篇诚实的疗效研究
has converged on the same finding, which is that the technique is not really the active ingredient. The therapist is, something about the therapist. and something that may be different for multiple therapists, which is the competition that drives people to sell and create and market new models. Good ones. And the apparatus has spent 40 years receiving that evidence that the therapist is the thing, and filing it and continuing to operate on this assumption that the technique is really what matters
都得出了相同的结论，即技术并不是真正的活性成分。治疗师才是，治疗师身上的某种特质。而这种特质在多位治疗师之间可能各不相同，这正是促使人们销售、创造和营销新模式的竞争所在。好的模式。该机构花了40年时间接收“治疗师才是关键”这一证据，将其归档，并继续在“技术才是重点”的假设下运作，
because the technique is what can be measured. And the therapist's interior cannot be measured. The apparatus has built itself around this comfortable fiction that the measure is the real, because the measurable is what people who cannot tolerate mystery in themselves and outside of themselves can defend and can see. And if they can't see it, it's not real. And that's the thesis. I'm going to defend that again. You know, the work of psychotherapy is irreducibly mysterious, maybe to the therapist as much as the patient. In the specific sense that the active variables resist quantification and the apparatus that has captured American
因为技术是可以衡量的。而治疗师的内心是无法衡量的。该机构围绕着一个舒适的虚构构建了自身，即“可衡量即真实”，因为对于那些无法容忍自身及外部存在神秘感的人来说，可衡量的东西是可以辩护和看见的。如果他们看不见，那它就不真实。这就是论点。我将再次捍卫这一点。你知道，心理治疗的工作是不可还原的神秘，也许对治疗师来说和对病人来说一样。具体来说，活跃变量拒绝量化，而那个捕获了美国
psychiatry is composed disproportionately of people who entered the field because they could not tolerate the mystery and the need to convert the work into something that could be procedurally administered. And that aligned with the interest of capital. But capital could not do that by itself. Capital needed the insecurity of the providers and the experts and the hierarchies of the profession. And the cold machine is the institutional form of the personal refusal to encounter what the work actually is, the work of therapy. The AI is what happens when the cold machine finally finds a delivery mechanism that does not require a human at all. And the field celebrates the arrival because the field has been preparing for the death of the warm ghost
精神病学的机构，其成员不成比例地由那些进入该领域是因为无法容忍神秘感、需要将工作转化为可程序化管理的人组成。这与资本的利益相一致。但资本无法独自做到这一点。资本需要提供者、专家和职业等级制度的不安全感。而冷酷的机器是个人拒绝面对工作本质（即治疗工作）的制度化形式。人工智能是当冷酷的机器终于找到一种完全不需要人类的交付机制时所发生的结果。而该领域庆祝它的到来，因为该领域一直在为温暖幽灵的死亡做准备，
the whole time without really admitting that this was the destination. Because they didn't know. Again, you could hold a gun to these people's heads. Just because you're motivated and building towards an end does not mean that you know what that end is. And this is the end that they will. wanted. But it's not the end that they knew they wanted or what it meant. And a lot of them will post about it on LinkedIn and complain while furthering the very apparatus that got us to this point. So I'm going to start this episode in a specific room because I need you to see what is actually there. Before I tell you what is going to replace it, because when it's replaced it, it probably will be too late. And these things won't die. They'll just go into fields other than American psychology,
却从未真正承认这就是终点。因为他们不知道。再说一次，就算你拿枪指着这些人的头。仅仅因为你有动力并朝着一个目标努力，并不意味着你知道那个目标是什么。这就是他们想要的终点。但这不是他们知道自己想要的终点，也不是他们知道那意味着什么。他们中的许多人会在领英上发帖抱怨，同时却在推动那个把我们带到这一点的机构。所以我将从一个特定的房间开始这一集，因为我需要你们看到那里实际存在的东西。在我告诉你们什么将取代它之前，因为当它被取代时，可能就太晚了。而这些东西不会消亡。它们只是会进入美国心理学以外的领域，
which is sad. That's the field I work in, and it's the field that I want to see succeed and survive. So picture a room, two chairs, a lamp, tissues, a rug, a print on the wall of something that is, you know, meaningless and obtrusive is not going to distract, like a tree or a butterfly or something. And it'll target, you know, like a brown with a swirl in a bird somewhere.
这很可悲。这是我工作的领域，也是我希望看到它成功并生存下去的领域。所以想象一个房间，两把椅子，一盏灯，纸巾，一块地毯，墙上挂着一幅画，画着一些无意义且不突兀、不会让人分心的东西，比如一棵树或一只蝴蝶之类的。它会瞄准，你知道，比如棕色背景，带点漩涡，还有一只鸟。
Two people, one of them's a therapist who's been doing this for 15 or 20 years. The other is a patient who's tried everything. Six therapists, four psychiatrists, eight medications, two rounds of manualizable CBT, a week of intensive outpatient, a residential stay. You know, largely the kind of patients that come to me. They're chart lists six different diagnoses collected across the years, contradictory and redundant, and none of them describing what the patient feels and actually lived with, all prescribed, you know, or all given to them by providers in the diagnostic model, the biomedical model, that's supposed to result in consistent psychiatric diagnoses, but hasn't.
两个人，其中一个是做了15或20年的治疗师。另一个是尝试过一切的病人。六个治疗师，四个精神科医生，八种药物，两轮可手册化的CBT，一周的强化门诊，一次住院治疗。你知道，这基本上就是来找我的那种病人。他们的病历上列出了多年来收集的六种不同的诊断，相互矛盾且冗余，没有一个能描述病人实际感受和生活状态的，所有这些都是由诊断模型、生物医学模型中的提供者给出的，这些模型本应产生一致的精神病学诊断，但并没有。
Something that is happening in that room will not appear in any randomized controlled trial. The therapist is doing something that has no CPT code, no manual, no protocol, and she's paying attention in a way that the apparatus cannot measure. Because the thing that that therapist, I said she, but it could be a guy, it doesn't matter, is paying attention to has no measurement instrument. And the reason that it has no measurement instrument is that the thing is not located inside, of either of them. It is located in the space between them, and the space between them is by definition what the apparatus cannot see. We can only be felt, and numbers do not feel. What is happening is the
那个房间里正在发生的事情不会出现在任何随机对照试验中。治疗师正在做一些没有CPT代码、没有手册、没有协议的事情，她正在以一种机构无法衡量的方式保持专注。因为那位治疗师（我说她，但也可以是他，没关系）所关注的东西没有测量工具。而它没有测量工具的原因是，那个东西并不位于他们任何一个人的内部。它位于他们之间的空间里，而他们之间的空间，根据定义，是该机构无法看到的。我们只能被感知，而数字不会感知。正在发生的是
nervous system that has been living in chronic threat for 40 years is for the first time in memory registering another nervous system as safe. Not the idea of safety, not the cognitive assessment of safety, the felt state of being accompanied by another animal who will not hurt you. Something that is very old now is happening ancient. Something that predates language, predates the diagnostic manual, predates American psychiatry, predates the apparatus and all its works. The therapist has been trained in something, but she is doing that, or he is doing that, right now, or Zay is doing that.
一个在慢性威胁中生活了40年的神经系统，在记忆中第一次将另一个神经系统登记为安全。不是安全的概念，不是对安全的认知评估，而是被另一个不会伤害你的动物陪伴的感受状态。某种非常古老的东西正在发生，远古的。某种先于语言、先于诊断手册、先于美国精神病学、先于该机构及其所有运作的东西。治疗师受过某种训练，但她正在做那个，或者他正在做那个，此时此刻，或者他们正在做那个。
Pronome doesn't matter. The training got them to this room. But it isn't just that the therapist sees the patient and is not the rest of the because there's lots of formalized models of therapy that are not threatening, but they can't see you. And there's lots of systems, like the diagnostic systems, that can see you, but they cannot love you. The real encounter is to be seen and to be held and loved at the same time. The person is seeing things that the patient doesn't see about themselves. the person is understanding things that the patient may not understand about themselves.
代词不重要。训练把他们带到了这个房间。但这不仅仅是治疗师看到了病人，因为有很多形式化的治疗模式并不具有威胁性，但它们看不见你。而且有很多系统，比如诊断系统，能看见你，但它们无法爱你。真正的相遇是被看见、被接纳并同时被爱。那个人正在看到病人自己没有看到的关于他们自己的东西。那个人正在理解病人自己可能不理解的关于他们自己的东西。
And at the same time, the, and at the same time, the therapist's nervous system is not rebelling against what they see. There is no avoidance. There is clarity. And that is the closest that I can articulate to the ingredient of what works, is that you are witnessing and you are not flinching. When many people have had people who accept them avoidantly, but they don't really, feel witnessed or held. And there's a lot of people who have been seen and they don't feel loved. And there's a lot of people who have been loved without feeling seen. And the goal of therapy, the goal of the successful ingredient of change is when that witnessing can be accompanied by an
与此同时，治疗师的神经系统并没有反抗他们所看到的。没有回避。有的是清晰。这就是我能表达的关于“什么有效”的成分最接近的描述，那就是你在见证，而且你没有退缩。当许多人遇到过以回避方式接纳他们的人时，他们并没有真正感到被见证或被接纳。有很多被看见的人，他们并没有感到被爱。有很多被爱的人，却没有感到被看见。治疗的目标，成功改变的活性成分的目标，是当那种见证能够伴随着一种
acceptance. And there is a limited, there are some formulas that are better than others, but there is a limited extent to which you can formulate that process. And that is the river that has run underground while the apparatus was building walls. It never stopped being there and it never could stop because the thing happening in the room is not a modality that the apparatus can credential or withhold. It's a capacity built in the human nervous system. And the question of whether it gets exercised depends on whether the clinician has been trained to recognize it and trust it and follow it. And this is what the language model can't do, the LLM or the AI. Not in 10 years and not in 100. The large language model doesn't have a nervous system. It has no body. What it has
接纳时。有一些公式比其他的更好，但你可以公式化该过程的程度是有限的。这就是当该机构在筑墙时，一直在地下流淌的河流。它从未停止存在，也永远无法停止，因为房间里发生的事情不是该机构可以认证或扣留的模式。它是人类神经系统中内置的一种能力。而它是否得到锻炼，取决于临床医生是否受过训练去识别它、信任它并跟随它。这就是语言模型做不到的，无论是LLM还是AI。10年内做不到，100年内也做不到。大语言模型没有神经系统。它没有身体。它拥有的是
What it has is prescriptions and intellectualized information and an approximation of what it thinks empathy sounds like, which a lot of therapists have been trying to do too. I'm not saying that it's worse when an LLM does it than when they do it. They shouldn't do it either. This approximation of understanding this, I totally understand what you're going through. It's so frustrating when this happens. You know, my guidance counselor in high school used to always, when you came into the room, would be like, I understand what you're feeling. Could you tell me what it is then? Oh, no, I can't.
处方、理智化的信息，以及对它认为同理心听起来是什么样子的近似，这也是许多治疗师一直在尝试做的。我并不是说当LLM这样做时比他们做时更糟。他们也不应该这样做。这种对理解的近似，“我完全理解你的感受。当这种情况发生时，真是太令人沮丧了。”你知道，我高中的辅导员总是这样，当你走进房间时，他会说：“我理解你的感受。”你能告诉我那是什么吗？“哦，不，我不能。”
What are you feeling? Why did you just say that to me? You know, the macro asks what the micro asks. And I've said this every episode. I'm going to say it now because this is the episode where the answer matters the most. Or we're creeping up on what the ultimate answer is. The way that the field defends a failed paradigm against its own data is the same way that a patient defends a failed self-image against their own felt experience.
“你感觉到了什么？你刚才为什么要那样对我说话？”你知道，宏观询问微观所问的问题。我每一集都说过这个。我现在要说，因为这是答案最重要的一集。或者我们正在接近终极答案。该领域捍卫一个失败的范式以对抗其自身数据的方式，与病人捍卫一个失败的自我形象以对抗其自身感受经验的方式是一样的。
The institutional dissociation is the personal dissociation. It's just scaled. It's just exponentially built. The apparatus is the patient writ large. The worst parts of the patient writ large. The parts that they're coming in to change. And so it is impossible for the apparatus to change those parts of the patient. And the question of whether the field can grow is the same question as whether the individual practitioner can grow,
制度性的解离就是个人的解离。它只是被放大了。它只是呈指数级增长。该机构就是被放大的病人。被放大的病人最糟糕的部分。他们进来想要改变的部分。因此，该机构不可能改变病人的那些部分。而该领域能否成长的问题，与个体从业者能否成长的问题是一样的，
which is the same question as whether the individual patient can grow, which is the question that has always been worth asking. It's the same question of whether or not you can teach psychotherapy from one person who is good at it to somebody who wants to do it but can't yet. And so the apparatus has one remaining move here, which is to hand the practice of psychotherapy over to an algorithm and declare the problem finally solved. And the infrastructure for this is already being built. You know, BetterHelp is the most obvious example, but it's not the only one. You know, Teledocque Mental Health, Talkspace, Cerebral, which briefly imploded when they hit a regulatory scrutiny for two seconds. It's just been followed by a dozen successors.
这与个体病人能否成长的问题是一样的，这始终是一个值得提出的问题。这与你是否能把心理治疗从一个擅长它的人传授给一个想做但还不会的人的问题是一样的。所以该机构在这里还有一个剩下的动作，那就是把心理治疗的实践交给算法，并宣布问题终于解决了。而这方面的基础设施已经在建设中。你知道，BetterHelp是最明显的例子，但它不是唯一的。你知道，Teledoc Mental Health、Talkspace、Cerebral，后者在受到监管审查两秒钟后就崩溃了。它只是被十几个继任者跟随。
You can't kill these things. It's a system. And the model is consistent across them. A tech company builds an app that matches a patient with licensed clinicians, often with packages or some subscription model, like all you can eat therapy in a month except, oops, there's nothing available when you want to schedule. So how much can you really eat?
你杀不死这些东西。这是一个系统。而且它们的模式是一致的。一家科技公司开发了一个应用程序，将病人与持证临床医生匹配，通常带有套餐或某种订阅模式，就像一个月内无限量治疗，除了，哎呀，当你想要预约时根本没空位。所以你真的能吃多少呢？
And it delivers the session through video or chat. And they're always there a few. It's like a best friend. The thing that's missing from the world, you can now get through this. And then, you know, It handles the billing and collects the data. And the patient pays a subscription fee.
它通过视频或聊天提供会话。而且它们总是像个好朋友一样。世界上缺失的东西，你现在可以通过这个得到。然后，你知道，它处理账单并收集数据。病人支付订阅费。
You sign a waiver that lets AI process all of this stuff and that your sessions be recorded, of course. And then that's routed through this employer wellness program so that employers see this as cheaper than paying for insurance for you or having an EAP, you know, employee assistance program. And the clinician is contracted, you know, as this independent gig worker like Uber or Amazon delivery. They're paid per session. at the rates that the platform sets with minimal professional autonomy over caseload or scheduling. And what kind of providers are going to sign up for this?
你签署一份豁免书，允许人工智能处理所有这些东西，当然还要录制你的会话。然后通过员工健康计划进行路由，这样雇主就会认为这比为你支付保险或拥有EAP（员工援助计划）更便宜。而临床医生是签约的，你知道，作为像优步或亚马逊快递那样的独立零工。他们按会话付费，按照平台设定的费率，对病例量或排程几乎没有专业自主权。会有什么样的提供者报名参加这个？
What kind of providers do you think that you're going to get? And it's what they've always wanted, you know, to have all this data to make therapy more efficient based on figuring out all this technique that can be part of the apparatus but not part of the human to really get it what works. So it can be the most evidence-based kind of therapy ever. The session is no longer a private conversation
你认为你会得到什么样的提供者？这正是他们一直想要的，你知道，拥有所有这些数据，基于找出所有这些技术来使治疗更有效率，这些技术可以成为机构的一部分，但不能成为人类的一部分，从而真正实现什么有效。所以它可以成为有史以来最循证的治疗。会话不再是房间里两个人之间的私人对话，
between two people in a room. It's a data event. Everything that happens is, The patient's chat logs are stored. The video is sometimes recorded. The clinician's response times are tracked. The outcomes against whatever metrics the platform has decided constitutes outcomes. Usually the PHQ 9 or the GAD 7 scores that the patient self-report at the beginning and the end of the engagement. And the data is the product. The person purchasing the data is the real customer, not the patient trying to get well. Therapy is just this loss leader that gets you to the real product. And the company is not a business to deliver. therapy, the company is in the business to capture the data that therapy produces and monetize it. Oh, but don't worry, it's not for bad reasons. We need all of this data so that we can finally break down the walls, see into the therapy room, and do better research studies and meta-analysis on the variables that actually produce change because we care so much about you.
它是一个数据事件。发生的一切都是，病人的聊天记录被存储。视频有时会被录制。临床医生的响应时间被追踪。针对平台认为构成结果的任何指标的结果。通常是病人在参与开始和结束时自我报告的PHQ-9或GAD-7分数。数据就是产品。购买数据的人才是真正的客户，而不是试图康复的病人。治疗只是让你接触到真正产品的“引流品”。而公司不是为了提供治疗而经营，公司是为了捕获治疗产生的数据并将其货币化。哦，但别担心，这不是为了坏原因。我们需要所有这些数据，以便我们最终能够打破墙壁，看进治疗室，并对实际产生改变的变量进行更好的研究和荟萃分析，因为我们非常关心你。
You know, BetterHelp was fined by the FTC for selling user data to Facebook and Snapchat, including the fact that users had sought mental health treatment and what they had sought for despite explicit promises that the data would not be shared and the fact that this was a violation of HIPAA law. And the fine was a rounding era in the company's revenue. You know, they make more than they do selling the data. And this was done so that if you went to therapy and you said that your mom died, Facebook could target you with ads that said this crystal helps magically through the planet Venus for people who have a dead mom. That's how it was used. And the next move, the one the industry is openly planning for is the replacement of the human
你知道，BetterHelp因向Facebook和Snapchat出售用户数据而被联邦贸易委员会罚款，包括用户寻求心理健康治疗的事实以及他们寻求治疗的原因，尽管有明确承诺数据不会被共享，且这违反了HIPAA法律。而罚款只是该公司收入中的一个四舍五入的误差。你知道，他们卖数据赚的钱比罚款多。这样做是为了让你去治疗时说你妈妈去世了，Facebook就能向你投放广告，说这种水晶通过金星能神奇地帮助那些死了妈妈的人。这就是它的用途。而下一步，行业正在公开计划的，是用大语言模型取代人类
clinician with a large language model. Why pay a contractor $60 a session when you can run an LLM that produces text that is statistically indistinguishable from what a therapist would say anyway if they were good? Because what the LLM says is the most evidence base. So the closer the therapist gets to that, the better of a therapist they are. Why pay anyone at all when the model can scale to millions of users simultaneously at near zero marginal costs? The technology is already being developed. There are multiple startups offering AI therapy right now, and the models pass surface-level tests of therapeutic response. They produce plausible reflections, reasonable refrains, appropriate sounding empathy. They do all this without requiring a licensure board or a training
临床医生。当你可以运行一个LLM，产生在统计学上与治疗师如果他们优秀的话会说的话无法区分的文本时，为什么要付给承包商每节课60美元呢？因为LLM所说的是最循证的。所以治疗师越接近那个，他们就是越好的治疗师。当模型可以以接近零的边际成本同时扩展到数百万用户时，为什么要付钱给任何人呢？这项技术已经在开发中。现在有多个初创公司提供AI治疗，这些模型通过了治疗反应的表面测试。它们产生合理的反思、合理的克制、听起来适当的同理心。它们做所有这些，而不需要执照委员会或培训
program or a clinical supervisor or any of the slow human infrastructure that the actual therapy requires. And one of the things that's the most terrifying to me is I've had multiple people reach out and say, yeah, yeah, yeah, I don't like Silicon Valley either, all of these things, whatever. And these are providers, pretty high up business people, and then sometimes patients, or not patients of mine, but patients of other therapists that say, you know, I get all that and I'm afraid of these things too, but I've tried therapy multiple times. And I went to this AI group where I went to a chat bot. And the advice that it gave me was better than I got in therapy. That is evidence of my point. I'm not saying that AI is, that there's this wonderful therapeutic
项目或临床主管或实际治疗所需的任何缓慢的人类基础设施。最让我感到恐惧的事情之一是，我曾多次有人联系我说，是的，是的，是的，我也不喜欢硅谷，所有这些东西，等等。这些是提供者，相当高层的商业人士，有时是病人，或者不是我的病人，而是其他治疗师的病人，他们说，你知道，我明白所有这些，我也害怕这些东西，但我尝试过多次治疗。我去过这个AI小组，或者我去过一个聊天机器人。它给我的建议比我在治疗中得到的更好。这就是我观点的证据。我并不是说AI是，我花了七集时间谈论的那个美妙的治疗
apparatus that I've spent seven episodes talking about out there, and that AI that is getting worse every single year, and that AI is this villain that's going to take away the wonderful, warm, fuzzy relationship by the fire that you have with your therapist. I'm saying that this thing is dying, and AI is the coffin nail that it is dead. And the fact that AI is better than a lot of people working should fill you with horror, not with hope. You know, the AI therapists, they don't have to work in the deepest sense to succeed commercially. They only have to work well enough to produce a PHQ 9 score that looks acceptable in a 12-week follow-up, which is all the apparatus was measuring anyway. And once we measure it once and publish the study, we're just going to assume that it
机构就在那里，而AI每年都在变糟，AI是那个会夺走你与治疗师在火炉旁那种美妙、温暖、模糊关系的恶棍。我是在说这个东西正在死亡，而AI是它死亡的棺材钉。而且AI比许多工作的人更好的事实应该让你感到恐惧，而不是希望。你知道，AI治疗师，它们不需要在最深层的意义上工作就能在商业上成功。它们只需要工作得足够好，产生一个在12周随访中看起来可以接受的PHQ-9分数，这本来就是该机构一直在衡量的。一旦我们衡量一次并发表研究，我们就会假设它
works forever and probably never research it again. We'll just hold that up as evidence-based practice for the rest of time. A lot of these studies people fight about, no, no, no, it worked. I mean, what, 15 years ago, you have two studies that said it worked? And now we're marketing. this is solved? I'm saying it's not solved and that the human psyche doesn't work that way. Culture changes. Things change. We have to keep measuring these things. You know, the LLMs will be declared evidence base. The insurance companies will cover them when the human clinician will be priced out of the market. And the deepest work and the work that requires two nervous systems together in a room will become an unaffordable luxury available only to patients wealthy enough to pay out
永远有效，可能再也不会研究它了。我们将永远把它作为循证实践来坚持。人们争论的很多这些研究，不，不，不，它有效。我是说，什么，15年前，你有两项研究说它有效？现在我们正在营销这个已经解决了？我说它没有解决，人类心理不是那样运作的。文化在变。事情在变。我们必须继续衡量这些东西。你知道，LLM将被宣布为循证。当人类临床医生被挤出市场时，保险公司将覆盖它们。而最深层的工作，以及需要两个神经系统在房间里一起工作的工作，将成为一种负担不起的奢侈品，只有富裕到足以支付
a pocket for the kind of therapy that apparatus no longer remembers. But the bad thing about that is that at that price point, the patient has too much power. The patient has enough power to make sure that the therapist doesn't challenge them. You know, look at these gurus in Silicon Valley that occasionally have a couple, you know, credentials or PhDs in something. But there's scandals all the time because they charge, you know, $500,000 an hour and they're trying to live in, you know, Palo Alto. They're trying to afford this stuff. And that means that the relationship is not fair to the patient because the patient can essentially pay for a yes man.
自付费用的病人才能获得，因为该机构不再记得那种治疗了。但坏处在于，在那个价格点上，病人拥有太多的权力。病人有足够的权力确保治疗师不会挑战他们。你知道，看看硅谷那些偶尔有几个证书或博士学位的导师。但丑闻不断，因为他们收费，你知道，每小时50万美元，他们试图住在，你知道，帕洛阿尔托。他们试图负担这些东西。这意味着这种关系对病人来说是不公平的，因为病人本质上可以为一个唯唯诺诺的人买单。
And that happens a lot of times in these communities. Look at how the American generational wound has changed over time. Just to do how the average American patient has changed, you know, in pace or against pace. of American clinical psych. The greatest generation got the depression and, you know, the war, and they organized around scarcity and duty, all sleeping I'm dead. And the wound that the generation was over-identified with, you know, the role of the provider, the suppression of the vulnerable child, the demand that emotion be so subordinated to function.
这在这些社区中经常发生。看看美国代际创伤是如何随时间变化的。仅仅看看普通美国病人是如何变化的，你知道，在节奏上或对抗节奏上。美国临床心理学。最伟大的一代经历了萧条和，你知道，战争，他们围绕稀缺和责任组织起来，所有睡觉我都死了。而这一代人过度认同的创伤，你知道，提供者的角色，对脆弱儿童的压制，对情感必须服从于功能的要求。
You know, they love their kids through this material provision and sacrifice of their own presence as humans for performance, you know, in a market. And most of them never went to therapy. And they didn't have a language for it. And then they drank. But they still were relatively functional and they had this kind of wisdom and they had a life that was more or less fulfilling. That was available to them. You know, the boomers got the inheritance of all that suppression.
你知道，他们通过这种物质供应和牺牲自己作为人类的存在来爱他们的孩子，为了表现，你知道，在市场上。他们大多数人从未去过治疗。他们没有语言来描述它。然后他们喝酒。但他们仍然相对有功能，他们有这种智慧，他们有或多或少令人满足的生活。那是他们可以获得的。你知道，婴儿潮一代继承了所有这些压制。
And the countercultural rebellion of the 60s and the 70s was the first generational attempt to name what had been suppressed. And we traced in episode four how that rebellion failed. and got absorbed into market individualism that promised self-actualization through consumption. You know, the boomer wound is the inflation of the self into a project of personal optimization. The boomer narcissism is this downstream of an actual psychological injury, the experience of being raised by parents who could not be present, met with a culture that told them the response to find themselves through buying things, having experiences, and this is what got passed forward.
而60年代和70年代的反文化叛乱是第一次试图命名被压制的东西的代际尝试。我们在第四集追踪了那种叛乱是如何失败的，并被市场个人主义所吸收，这种个人主义承诺通过消费实现自我实现。你知道，婴儿潮一代的创伤是自我膨胀为一个个人优化项目。婴儿潮一代的自恋是实际心理伤害的下游，即被无法在场的父母抚养长大的经历，遇到了一种告诉他们通过购买东西、拥有体验来寻找自己的文化，这就是传递下去的东西。
And then Gen X got the latchkey years. Their parents were often boomers and they were in the workplace and were in a divorce. And the Gen X wound is abandonment. The Gen X coping strategy is ironic detachment. You wore baggy pants and did like, you know, grunge or something. And you didn't ask, you know, what you need because you have decided in advance that asking for that would be embarrassing. Cynicism became this armor. You know, your response to advertising when you had no control over the corporations was just a make
然后X世代经历了钥匙儿童时代。他们的父母通常是婴儿潮一代，他们在工作场所，处于离婚状态。而X世代的创伤是遗弃。X世代的应对策略是讽刺性的疏离。你穿着宽松的裤子，做着，你知道，垃圾摇滚之类的东西。而且你没有问，你知道，你需要什么，因为你已经提前决定问那个会很尴尬。愤世嫉俗成了这种盔甲。你知道，当你对公司没有控制权时，你对广告的反应只是去嘲笑
fun of the advertising, but that didn't really solve a problem. And you can recognize, you know, Gen X sometimes, like in culture, because they will narrate their own suffering with sarcasm before you have a chance to take it seriously. And millennials are my generation, and we saw this trap. We could see it, the student loans, the precarity of the economic future. We were hooked up to the firehose of information of the internet, which, you know, kind of took Gen X off guard. When Gen X is graduating college, they think that they're going to go on to New York to make like zines and rock magazines and publishing and like all this stuff that's just gone. They're struggling to open a PDF when like, you know, these babies are like, have iPhones at six. And, um, you know,
广告，但这并没有真正解决问题。你可以识别，你知道，X世代有时，比如在文化中，因为他们会在你有机会认真对待之前，用讽刺来叙述他们自己的痛苦。而千禧一代是我的这一代，我们看到了这个陷阱。我们可以看到它，学生贷款，经济未来的不确定性。我们被连接到互联网的信息消防栓上，这，你知道，有点让X世代措手不及。当X世代大学毕业时，他们认为他们会去纽约制作像杂志和摇滚杂志和出版之类的东西，而所有这些东西都消失了。当，你知道，这些婴儿像六岁就有iPhone时，他们还在努力打开PDF。而且，嗯，你知道，
these political institutions had stopped functioning by the time millennials were coming out. They increasingly just had no hope for any sort of ecological or economic future. Um, and they saw the boomer trap of self optimization as meaning and they said, no, that's not really real. Um, that doesn't work. We're not going to do that. And then. And then I guess the refusal was correct, but there was no antidote. You know, hanging up a bunch of Edison classic millennial light bulbs on strings at your brewery and then being like, well, we have to have like a personal relationship with the person that makes the beer or something. Like, it's like that dream kind of imploded. Like it didn't really work.
当千禧一代出来时，这些政治机构已经停止运作了。他们越来越对任何形式的生态或经济未来没有希望。嗯，他们看到了婴儿潮一代自我优化的陷阱作为意义，他们说，不，那不是真的。嗯，那行不通。我们不会那样做。然后。然后我想拒绝是正确的，但没有解药。你知道，在你的啤酒厂挂上一串串爱迪生经典千禧灯泡，然后说，嗯，我们必须和制造啤酒的人有某种个人关系之类的。就像，那个梦想有点内爆了。就像它并没有真正起作用。
It was this fake world, fake alternative, because eventually you have kids and you've got to go to work and you're trying to figure out how to survive. Same thing that happened, you know, to the hippies, basically, but less dramatic. So where did that pain go? I mean, the people that didn't get hit by the opiate crisis, which hit millennials harder than any other generation, I mean, it largely became this nostalgia. We have no vision for a future, but we can go back and play with toys. I mean, I saw a study yesterday that the amount of toys bought by adults because of millennials has now surpassed the amount of money spent on toys for children.
这是一个虚假的世界，虚假的替代品，因为最终你有孩子了，你必须去工作，你试图弄清楚如何生存。和发生在，你知道，嬉皮士身上的事情一样，基本上，但没那么戏剧性。那么那种痛苦去哪了？我是说，那些没有受到阿片类药物危机打击的人，阿片类药物危机对千禧一代的打击比任何其他一代都严重，我是说，它在很大程度上变成了这种怀旧。我们对未来没有愿景，但我们可以回去玩玩具。我是说，我昨天看到一项研究，成年人购买的玩具数量因为千禧一代现在已经超过了为儿童购买玩具所花的钱。
And a lot of that is because there's no vision of a future. They're just looking back to things that they were nostalgic for, that were on TV. Even when the culture was at its peak, you know, something like Tim and Eric, the Tim and Eric Awesome Show, great job, you know, Eric Wareham, Tim Heidegger, then they were preempting this. You know, the things that you see on a show like that were visual techniques from the 70s and 80s.
而这很大程度上是因为没有未来的愿景。他们只是回顾他们怀旧的东西，那些在电视上的东西。即使当文化处于巅峰时，你知道，像《Tim and Eric》，《Tim and Eric Awesome Show, Great Job》，你知道，Eric Wareham，Tim Heidegger，他们当时就在预见这一点。你知道，你在那样的节目中看到的东西是70年代和80年代的视觉技术。
They weren't for them the 2000s when, or the aughts, you know, in the 2010s when that stuff was being made. It was inherently this sort of like hopeless looking back because there is no solution culture. And now Gen Z is inheriting this dissociation as they start, you know, thinking, basically. From the very beginning, they don't even have hope before they go to college. They never knew anything else. They came of age inside this algorithm swimming amongst this information. And the screen as this co-regulator was something that happened in elementary school. They spent more time looking at a Chromebook than a teacher than a person.
它们不是为他们2000年代，或者00年代，你知道，在2010年代当那些东西被制作时。它本质上是这种绝望的回顾，因为没有解决方案文化。而现在Z世代正在继承这种解离，当他们开始，你知道，思考，基本上。从一开始，他们在上大学之前甚至都没有希望。他们从来不知道其他任何东西。他们在这种算法中长大，在这些信息中游泳。而屏幕作为这种共同调节者是发生在小学的事情。他们花在看Chromebook上的时间比看老师、看人的时间还多。
They spent more time looking at a little animated avatar that said, I don't know, ancient Egyptians did this in 600 BC or 12 BC, I'm not sure. Do you want a clue? While the teachers like sitting at their desk trying to manage the algorithmic functioning of the Chromebook cart, the diagnostic identity is the substitute for the selfhood that the apparatus left them because the apparatus stripped out the deeper categories of meaning over the previous 50 years. And the only language for selfhood that remained was the language of a disorder. That's why these kids think of basically the DSM like it's a astrology. To watch an 11 and a 12-year-old on Reddit talk about their identity in terms of pathology is pretty wild. They're not grown up yet. I am anxiety. I am Arfit or something. You know, not because the diagnosis are wrong, which a lot of times they are. If you can call me and say, I have dissociative identity disorder and one of my parts is Pikachu and one of my parts is Naruto and one of my parts of my parts of
他们花在看一个小动画头像上的时间更多，那个头像说，我不知道，古埃及人在公元前600年或公元前12年做了这个，我不确定。你想要个线索吗？当老师坐在桌子旁试图管理Chromebook车的算法运作时，诊断身份是该机构留给他们的自我感的替代品，因为该机构在过去50年里剥离了更深层的意义类别。而剩下的唯一自我感语言是障碍的语言。这就是为什么这些孩子认为DSM基本上就像占星术一样。在Reddit上看到一个11岁和12岁的孩子用病理学的术语谈论他们的身份是相当疯狂的。他们还没长大。我是焦虑。我是Arfit之类的。你知道，不是因为诊断是错的，很多时候它们是错的。如果你能打电话给我说，我有解离性身份障碍，我的一个部分是皮卡丘，我的一个部分是火影忍者，我的一个部分是我的部分，我的部分是
whatever. I mean, I see a lot of DID. It's very rare and most of those referrals come from psychiatrists. But if you can do that, you don't usually have DID. It's not that your suffering's not real. It's not that you're lying. It's that you are looking for an appropriate container for the dissociated neurosis of your emotional self inside of a diagnostic manual. And you find this disorder and it makes sense. And so it becomes the language of your pain, which is an enormous problem. An enormous problem. And that Gen Z wound that is the dissociation that began as a millennial coping mechanism became for the next cohort the only state of consciousness that they've ever known. They didn't lose contact with their bodies. They never had it. And they're growing up unmerged
什么的。我是说，我看到了很多DID。它非常罕见，而且大多数这些转诊来自精神科医生。但如果你能那样做，你通常没有DID。并不是说你的痛苦不真实。并不是说你在撒谎。而是你在诊断手册中寻找你情感自我的解离神经症的适当容器。你找到了这个障碍，它说得通。所以它成了你痛苦的语言，这是一个巨大的问题。一个巨大的问题。而那个Z世代的创伤，即作为千禧一代应对机制开始的解离，对于下一代来说成了他们所知的唯一意识状态。他们没有失去与身体的联系。他们从来没有过。而且他们正在长大，没有从
from the algorithm because they've never been merged with anything else. And this is setting you up for a cyberpunk dystopia where these kids are told that their bodies are the enemy and that they're They're supposed to break them and change them that they're bad. I don't know what this means for Gen Alpha. I don't even want to go that far. I mean, it's the first generation that's been algorithmically optimized at a developmental scale by social media systems that didn't even exist when their developmental theories were being written.
算法中合并出来，因为他们从来没有与任何其他东西合并过。这正在为你设置一个赛博朋克反乌托邦，这些孩子被告知他们的身体是敌人，他们应该打破它们并改变它们，他们是坏的。我不知道这对Alpha世代意味着什么。我甚至不想走那么远。我是说，这是第一代在发展规模上被社交媒体系统算法优化的一代，这些系统在他们的发展理论被编写时甚至不存在。
You know, their suffering looks different. Their language for it is going to be different. And their relationship to embodiment and identity and continuity is different. And the apparatus has nothing built for them. The apparatus has at most the same 12 sessions of CBT repurposed for a teen audience. We'll put another two letters after CVT to pretend it's a different thing. You know, with this treatment resistant by design population, that it's going to make the apparatus' numbers look even worse.
你知道，他们的痛苦表现形式不同。他们描述痛苦的语言也会不同。他们与具身性、身份认同和连续性的关系也不同。而现有的体制并没有为他们建立任何东西。体制最多只是把同样的12次认知行为疗法（CBT）重新包装，以适应青少年群体。我们会在CBT后面再加两个字母，假装它是另一种东西。你知道，对于这种被设计为“治疗抵抗”的人群，这只会让体制的数据看起来更糟糕。
And then its reaction to its numbers looking worse will be worse. Because when this system feels insecure, it doesn't change. It doubles down on what doesn't work. And that's the future. That is, this is the population that the apparatus has built and that is speeding towards oblivion. This is the last phase of this cold machine project. The nervous system that was asked 130 years ago to become compatible with the factory clock is now being asked to become compatible with the language of a model. It has mistaken diagnostic codes that were supposed to describe pathological elements of human experience for identity itself.
而当体制看到数据变差时，它的反应会更糟糕。因为当这个系统感到不安时，它不会改变。它会变本加厉地坚持那些无效的做法。这就是未来。也就是说，这是体制所塑造的人群，他们正加速走向遗忘。这是这台冷酷机器计划的最后阶段。130年前被要求与工厂时钟同步的神经系统，现在被要求与某种模型的语言同步。它错误地将本应描述人类经验病理要素的诊断代码，当成了身份认同本身。
and a lot of times political movements that were supposed to be reactions to negative material forces for identity. So it's not good. In the last 20 years, there's something that the field failed to notice. There's a series of clinical innovations that have been independently developed by different clinicians in different countries from different starting points that are converging on the same picture of what the mind is and how it heals. And the picture that they're converging on, and there were alternatives to this the whole time, you know, because you can't kill that river. You know, Tanya Lerman is this cultural anthropologist at Stanford, and she trained as an ethnographer, and she spent her career embedded in clinical and religious communities watching how minds work in context. In context, the thing that the machine can't do anymore.
很多时候，本应是对负面物质力量做出反应的政治运动，却变成了身份认同的工具。所以这并不好。在过去的20年里，这个领域忽略了一些事情。有一系列临床创新，是由不同国家的临床医生从不同的起点独立发展出来的，它们正汇聚成关于心智是什么以及如何治愈的同一幅图景。他们正在汇聚的这幅图景——而且一直以来都有替代方案，因为你无法扼杀那条河流。你知道，塔尼娅·勒尔曼（Tanya Lerman）是斯坦福大学的一位文化人类学家，她受过民族志学家的训练，职业生涯一直深入临床和宗教社区，观察心智如何在情境中运作。在情境中，这正是机器无法再做到的事情。
We've driven anthropology and philosophy and a lot of co-related fields out of psychotherapy. So her 2000 book, you know, book, you know, of two minds is this ethnography of American psychiatric residency training. And it's one of the few honest ones. I mean, one of the only ones anyway, but Lerman recruited people diagnosed with schizophrenia in three different places. San Mateo, California, Akra, Ghana, and then Jahani, India. And all of these people met criteria for schizophrenia under the DSM, all of them. And the team interviewed each participant about the content, the quality, the relational character of the voices that they heard, and what the voices said.
我们已经把人类学、哲学和许多相关领域从心理治疗中驱逐出去了。所以她2000年的书《两种心智》（Of Two Minds）是对美国精神科住院医师培训的民族志研究。它是为数不多的诚实著作之一。我是说，几乎是唯一的一本。勒尔曼在三个不同的地方招募了被诊断患有精神分裂症的人：加利福尼亚州的圣马特奥、加纳的阿克拉，以及印度的金奈。所有这些人都在DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）标准下符合精神分裂症的诊断，所有人都是。团队采访了每位参与者，询问他们所听到的声音的内容、质量、关系特征，以及这些声音说了什么。
Were they recognizable? Were they kind or cruel? And did they have a relationship with the person hearing them? any kind of relationship. And did the person have any control over them? Did the person consider the voices a problem? None of this data was terribly subtle in the story that it told. You know, the Americans, the patients in San Mateo,
它们是可以辨认的吗？它们是友善的还是残酷的？他们与听到这些声音的人之间有关系吗？任何形式的关系。那个人对它们有控制权吗？那个人认为这些声音是个问题吗？这些数据在它所讲述的故事中一点也不微妙。你知道，美国人，圣马特奥的患者，
almost uniformly described their voices as violent, intrusive, and hateful. The voices commanded them to hurt themselves or to hurt other people. And the voices were experienced as foreign, invading, and as evidence that something was deeply wrong with them. And the Americans hated their voices, and they wanted them gone. The voices were torment. You know, the Indians, the patients that they interviewed in Chennai, described something almost completely different.
几乎一致地将他们的声音描述为暴力、侵入性和充满仇恨的。这些声音命令他们伤害自己或伤害他人。这些声音被体验为外来的、入侵的，并被视为他们自身出了严重问题的证据。美国人讨厌他们的声音，他们希望这些声音消失。这些声音是一种折磨。你知道，印度人，他们在金奈采访的患者，描述的情况几乎完全不同。
Their voices were often family members, mothers, fathers, deceased relatives. The voices gave advice. The voices reminded them to do household chores. The voices were something sometimes irritating, but mostly they were experienced as part of a relational world that included both the living and the dead, a continuum, you know, something that was a part of meaning-making. And the Indian patients did not generally consider their voices evidence of disease. They considered them part of how the world worked.
他们的声音通常是家庭成员，母亲、父亲、已故的亲属。这些声音会给出建议。这些声音提醒他们做家务。这些声音有时令人恼火，但大多数时候，它们被体验为关系世界的一部分，这个世界既包括生者也包括死者，是一个连续体，你知道，是意义构建的一部分。印度患者通常不认为他们的声音是疾病的证据。他们认为这些声音是世界运作方式的一部分。
And some of the voices were unpleasant, but the voices as a category were not. In their experience, they were just a sign that something was happening and something needed to be paid attention to. And the people from Ghana, you know, they described something different. Their voices were often experienced as spiritual presences. God spoke to them. Their voices were frequently benign, helpful, morally instructive, and the Ghana patients often felt special, chosen or marked for a spiritual purpose. The voice hearing was not a private disease. It was part of a religious world that included direct contact with the divine and ancestral beings that included relevant information. And some of the voices were difficult, but the experience of hearing the voices was not
有些声音是不愉快的，但作为一类声音，它们并不令人反感。在他们的体验中，它们只是某种事情正在发生、需要被关注的信号。而来自加纳的人，你知道，他们描述了不同的情况。他们的声音通常被体验为精神存在。上帝与他们交谈。他们的声音通常是良性的、有帮助的、具有道德指导意义的，加纳患者通常感到自己很特别，是被选中的，或是为了某种精神目的而被标记的。听见声音不是一种私人疾病。它是宗教世界的一部分，包括与神圣和祖先存在直接接触，并包含相关信息。有些声音很难处理，但听见声音的体验对这些患者来说并不是
pathological to those patients. Now, go back. to that the wound speaks episode of this series. Psychosis, sometimes autism, and definitely conspiracy theories in a society. They are canaries in the coal mine for what's going to happen and where things are going. Lerman doesn't have an answer here. She's an ethnographer. Her argument is that the cultural framing doesn't just overlay an identical underlying experience. the cultural framing constitutes the experience.
病理性的。现在，回到本系列“伤口在说话”（The Wound Speaks）那一集。精神病，有时是自闭症，绝对还有社会中的阴谋论。它们是煤矿里的金丝雀，预示着将要发生什么以及事情正走向何方。勒尔曼在这里没有给出答案。她是一位民族志学家。她的论点是，文化框架不仅仅是覆盖在一种相同的潜在体验之上，文化框架构成了这种体验。
And when a culture is sick, psychosis will tell you that a culture is not working. We're a part of a culture, like a mental health apparatus. The Americans are not reporting the same voices that the Indians are reporting through a different filter. They don't have different associations. The Americans are having different voices, and the voices that the Americans here are violent and intrusive because the American framework, the framework of the medicalized cell, the framework of the bounded individual, the framework of pathology, as something foreign invading a clean self, of purity produces voices that have those properties.
当一种文化生病时，精神病会告诉你这种文化出了问题。我们是文化的一部分，就像心理健康体制一样。美国人报告的声音并不是通过不同的过滤器报告与印度人相同的声音。他们没有不同的联想。美国人听到的是不同的声音，而美国人听到的声音之所以暴力且具有侵入性，是因为美国框架——医疗化自我的框架、边界明确的个体框架、将病理视为外来入侵纯净自我的框架——产生了具有这些属性的声音。
And the voices in Ghana, what they hear are spiritual and morally instructive, because the Ghana framework, the framework of a poor itself that exists in relationship with ancestors and gods and spirits and a gentle, non-invasive, non-literal mythology produces voices that, have those properties and meaning that has that character. And the framework is not interpretation laid over a universal substrate. The framework is part of what generates the phenomenology. And this is a very strong claim. And Lerman backs it up with a lot of careful work.
而加纳的声音，他们听到的是精神上和道德上的指导，因为加纳的框架——一个存在于与祖先、神灵和灵魂关系中的自我框架，以及一种温和、非侵入性、非字面意义的神话——产生了具有那些属性的声音，以及具有那种特征的意义。这种框架不是覆盖在普遍基质上的解释。这种框架是产生现象学的一部分。这是一个非常强有力的主张。勒尔曼用大量严谨的工作支持了这一点。
And what I want to do is connect it to where we are going next in this episode, which is the predictive processing framework. Because what Lerman is saying, because what Lerman is saying, you know, ethnographically, is what Carl Fristin, who's a neuroscientist that works mainly with math, he's also a mathematician, has been saying computationally. And the two of them have been pointing at the same thing from completely different sides. I mean, even someone like Carl Jung, I think, is ending up through phenomenology
我想做的是把它与我们这一集接下来要讲的内容联系起来，即预测处理框架。因为勒尔曼在民族志上所说的，正是卡尔·弗里斯顿（Carl Friston）——一位主要研究数学的神经科学家，他也是一位数学家——在计算上所说的。他们两人一直在从完全不同的侧面指向同一件事。我的意思是，即使像卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）这样的人，我认为他最终也是通过现象学，
and just exploring his own kind of felt sense, or Eugene Glendon, who does the same thing. He's kind of a 70s somatic medicine guy. But they're entering into the same thing that Carl Fristin is saying with neurodine, neuroscience and numbers. You know, Carl Fristin is using numbers in a completely different way than Theodore Porter is critiquing or something like the evidence-based practice paradigm and its worst implementations I'm critiquing. You know, and Fristin basically says the brain is just this prediction machine. The problem with an organism is that it can stay alive if it can predict the future better, yet we can't see the future. So what do we do? So his answer is that,
仅仅是探索他自己那种感受，或者尤金·根德林（Eugene Gendlin），他也做同样的事情。他算是70年代躯体医学方面的人。但他们正在进入卡尔·弗里斯顿用神经动力学、神经科学和数字所说的同一领域。你知道，卡尔·弗里斯顿使用数字的方式与西奥多·波特（Theodore Porter）所批判的方式完全不同，或者与我所批判的循证实践范式及其最糟糕的实施方式完全不同。你知道，弗里斯顿基本上说大脑只是一个预测机器。有机体的问题在于，如果它能更好地预测未来，它就能活下去，但我们无法预见未来。那么我们该怎么办？所以他的答案是，
you know, the brain maintains this internal model of the world. And the internal model is built from cultural priors, you know, from learned expectations, from the high-level interpretive frameworks that the culture supplies. But when the brain generates a voice, the voice is not a raw sensory event. The voice is constructed by the brain's interpretation machinery, using whatever priors that the machinery has been trained on. And if the priors are American medicalized priors, the voice gets constructed as a violent intrusion. And if the priors are, you know, a Ghanaian spiritual prior, then the voice gets constructed as a divine address. Same neurological capacity, different cultural priors, different phenomenology, different outcome.
你知道，大脑维持着这个世界的内部模型。而内部模型是由文化先验构建的，你知道，来自习得的期望，来自文化提供的高层解释框架。但当大脑产生一个声音时，这个声音不是原始的感官事件。这个声音是由大脑的解释机制构建的，使用该机制所训练的任何先验知识。如果先验知识是美国医疗化的先验知识，那么这个声音就被构建为一种暴力的入侵。如果先验知识是，你知道，加纳的精神先验知识，那么这个声音就被构建为一种神圣的呼唤。相同的神经能力，不同的文化先验，不同的现象学，不同的结果。
But the apparatus is not able to absorb a critique or an understanding like that. The American outcomes are worse. And the American schizophrenia in Lerman Sample suffered more, hated their voices more, experienced more functional impairment than the Indians or the Ghanians. And the pathology framework, you know, the framework that the DSM produces and that American culture transmits makes the disease worse. You know, the cultural overlay is not a confounder of the universal disease. The cultural overlay is part of what determines how severe the disease is and how much the patient suffers. And the apparatus, by training the entire American population to interpret voice hearing as evidence of a foreign invader inside a clean self,
但体制无法吸收这样的批判或理解。美国的结果更糟糕。勒尔曼样本中的美国精神分裂症患者受苦更多，更讨厌他们的声音，比印度或加纳的患者经历了更多的功能障碍。而病理框架，你知道，DSM产生的框架以及美国文化传播的框架，使疾病变得更糟。你知道，文化覆盖层并不是普遍疾病的混杂因素。文化覆盖层是决定疾病严重程度以及患者受苦程度的一部分。而体制，通过训练整个美国人口将听见声音解释为清洁自我内部的外来入侵者的证据，
is a structurally implicated, you know, in producing this form of schizophrenia that is the hardest to live with. That even in America, you know, we have research studies like we talked about in the hearing the wound episode, the wound speaks episode, episode, episode four about conspiracy theories and psychotic delusions changing over time. What's if schizophrenia would become in the 1970s was not what it was before. And I don't think that it's a good thing or that people should live with it. And, you know, I've heard people make this critique that you could, you know,
在结构上参与了产生这种最难忍受的精神分裂症形式。即使在美国，你知道，我们也有研究，就像我们在“听见伤口”那一集、关于阴谋论和精神病妄想随时间变化的那一集（第四集）中讨论的那样。如果精神分裂症在70年代变成了现在的样子，那它以前并不是这样。我不认为这是一件好事，也不认为人们应该忍受它。而且，你知道，我听过人们提出这种批评，认为你可以，你知道，
just sort of accept schizophrenia until it goes away. Like Artie Lang, you know, had clinics like that in the 70s. And I don't know a ton about that. That's not what I'm saying. I do know people that their life is profoundly disrupted. And schizophrenia is something that does need to be medicated. I'm saying that we can learn from the way the rain works and what the data says. And that's really all that I'm saying there.
只是接受精神分裂症直到它消失。就像阿蒂·莱恩（Artie Laing）在70年代有那样的诊所。我对此了解不多。我不是那个意思。我确实认识一些生活受到严重干扰的人。精神分裂症确实需要药物治疗。我只是说我们可以从雨的运作方式和数据所显示的内容中学习。这真的是我想说的全部。
I'm not making a case for how we could treat it. That it is psychosis and conspiracy theories, again, are kind of a canary in the coal mine. And sometimes people that are, you know, very highly intuitive, sometimes like ASD type, highly intuitive people that understand systems really well. You know, they feel these things coming before they're here. And so I want to put this, you know, parallel finding, you know, which is the World Health Organization. You know, they did a pilot study of schizophrenia, which it's been replicated multiple times. the 70s, but, you know, the IPSS found repeatedly that patients with schizophrenia in low income and middle income countries had better long-term outcomes than patients with schizophrenia
我不是在为我们如何治疗它辩护。精神病和阴谋论，再次强调，是煤矿里的金丝雀。有时那些，你知道，非常直觉敏锐的人，有时像自闭症谱系类型、非常直觉敏锐、非常了解系统的人。你知道，他们在这些事情到来之前就能感觉到。所以我想提出这个，你知道，平行发现，你知道，就是世界卫生组织。你知道，他们做了一个精神分裂症的试点研究，已经被多次复制。70年代，但是，你知道，IPSS（国际精神分裂症试点研究）反复发现，低收入和中等收入国家的精神分裂症患者比
in high-income Western countries. And the finding has been controversial because people have tried to attribute it to, you know, selection bias or a measurement artifact or, you know, misdiagnosis, something. The data is not really the same. So apples to oranges, we can't compare it. But you look at the iPS study and then replicated something like that across a couple decades. It looks like apples to apples. Or closer than apples to oranges at least. So the basic finding is held up across decades. And it's that people with schizophrenia, you know, they recover more often.
高收入西方国家的精神分裂症患者有更好的长期预后。这一发现一直存在争议，因为人们试图将其归因于，你知道，选择偏差或测量伪影，或者，你知道，误诊，之类的东西。数据确实不太一样。所以苹果和橘子比，我们无法比较。但你看看IPSS研究，然后在过去几十年里复制了类似的东西。看起来像是苹果和苹果比。或者至少比苹果和橘子更接近。所以基本发现几十年来一直成立。那就是精神分裂症患者，你知道，他们恢复得更频繁。
They function better and they live more integrated lives in places where the medical apparatus is less dominant. And there could be a lot of reasons for that. Like there are other technological apparatuses that are less dominant in those cultures. And so you may be able to function better if you don't have to wake up at nine o'clock and go to a job. Or if you're able to subsistence farm, it just creates less problems when the world is less structured. And you have something that makes your ability to conform to a structure less. So there's other elements to that. But the apparatus is interventions, the chronic antipsychotic prescriptions, the institutional framing.
在医疗体制不那么占主导地位的地方，他们功能更好，生活也更融合。这可能有很多原因。比如在那些文化中，其他技术体制不那么占主导地位。所以如果你不必早上九点起床去上班，你可能能够更好地发挥功能。或者如果你能够自给自足地耕种，当世界结构不那么严密时，它产生的问题就更少。而且你拥有某种东西，使你适应结构的能力降低。所以还有其他因素。但体制的干预，长期的抗精神病药物处方，制度化的框架，
of the patient as a chronic case, the social isolation produced by the diagnostic identity, they are part of what produces the chronic course that the apparatus then treats as this inherent part of the disease. And Lerman's Voices Research and the IPSS data together form one of the stronger pieces of empirical evidence available for the layered model that I would propose is probably a better one than the way we think about diagnosis through numbers and checklist right now. And again, I'm not saying that, you know, diagnosis is meaningless or anything. I'm just saying that we need to think about the context of these things. We need to think about the role of symptoms in what we call mental illness or even self. And that looking at that with a little bit more context and looking at the
将患者视为慢性病例，诊断身份产生的社会孤立，它们是产生体制随后将其视为疾病固有部分的慢性病程的一部分。勒尔曼的声音研究和IPSS数据共同构成了我所提出的分层模型最有力的经验证据之一，我认为这可能比我们现在通过数字和清单来思考诊断的方式更好。再说一次，我不是说，你知道，诊断毫无意义。我只是说我们需要考虑这些事情的背景。我们需要思考症状在所谓的精神疾病甚至自我中的作用。并且用多一点背景来看待这些，看着
space between the numbers is important. So if we take seriously the anthropology and the sociology, the numbers from other professions, I think one of the things that emerges is that the cultural layer is causal of a lot of the stuff. Not just the biology. You know, it shapes what symptoms become, how patients experience them, how families respond, what outcomes are possible. And any model of psychopathology that does not have culture as a semi-load-bearing layer with mechanisms by which it shapes the other layers is not modeling reality. Only the black keys will tell you the story if you can hear them in the noise. There is something more human, unique against the melody rewritten every year by the year by the story. young, we hear it better, older when our ears lose the soft sounds losing wonder, but if we are not too careful gaining a sense of all.
数字之间的空间很重要。所以如果我们认真对待人类学和社会学，来自其他专业的数字，我认为出现的一件事是文化层是很多东西的因果。不仅仅是生物学。你知道，它塑造了症状变成什么，患者如何体验它们，家庭如何反应，什么样的结果是可能的。任何没有将文化作为半承重层、没有通过机制塑造其他层的精神病理学模型，都不是在模拟现实。只有黑键才能告诉你故事，如果你能在噪音中听到它们。有一种更人性、独特的东西，对抗着每年被故事重写的旋律。年轻时，我们听得更好；年老时，当我们的耳朵失去柔和的声音，失去惊奇感，但如果我们不小心，就会获得一种整体感。
The dirt has been so many things that it cannot remember the earth, cannot separate who it is from wonder in itself, because it is always waking up into a new creation. Pay what you owe The babe says as it cries Who do you think you are Asked wild flowers in the graveyard Remember something else Says the misspelled word in the suicide note And this is what Arthur Kleinman has kind of been saying since 1980
泥土已经变成了太多的东西，以至于它无法记住大地，无法将它是谁与它自身的惊奇分离开来，因为它总是在新的创造中醒来。你欠什么就付什么，婴儿哭着说。你以为你是谁？墓地里的野花问道。记住别的东西，自杀遗书里拼错的词写道。这就是亚瑟·克莱曼（Arthur Kleinman）自1980年以来一直在说的。
Kleinman is a psychiatrist and a medical anthropologist at Harvard and his books, particularly recent thinking psychiatry and the illness narratives are the foundational text of cultural psychiatry. And Kleinman developed the concept of idioms of distress, which is the recognition that different cultures have different available vocabularies for expressing suffering, and that the vocabulary is not just a translation problem. The vocabulary shapes what the suffering becomes. So a Chinese patient in 1980 presenting with what an American psychiatrist would call depression, often described their suffering as physical exhaustion and bodily pain. And the semantic presentation was not a defense against the real psychological depression underneath.
克莱曼是哈佛大学的精神病学家和医学人类学家，他的书，特别是近期的《精神病学思考》和《疾病叙事》，是文化精神病学的奠基文本。克莱曼提出了“痛苦的习语”（idioms of distress）概念，即认识到不同的文化有不同的可用词汇来表达痛苦，而且这种词汇不仅仅是一个翻译问题。词汇塑造了痛苦变成了什么。所以1980年的一位中国患者，表现出美国精神科医生所说的抑郁症，通常将他们的痛苦描述为身体疲惫和身体疼痛。这种躯体表现并不是对底层真实心理抑郁的防御。
The semantic presentation was the experience. It was the way that this person in 1980, based on their culture, experienced depression. Was, I'm hurting and I'm tired. And the American move to diagnose it as mask depression and prescribe an SSRI imposed a cultural framework that didn't fit and that produced outcomes that did not match the framework's predictions. And I'm not 100% of Kleinian. We're just looking at different people who have actually are serious scholars that publish about these ideas. And then I leave it up to you how these may fit together.
这种躯体表现就是体验本身。这就是1980年那个基于他们文化的人体验抑郁的方式。是，我感到疼痛，我感到疲倦。而美国将其诊断为“隐匿性抑郁症”并开出SSRIs（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）处方的做法，强加了一种不合适的文化框架，并产生了与框架预测不符的结果。我不是100%的克莱曼主义者。我们只是在看不同的、实际上是严肃的学者，他们发表了关于这些想法的文章。然后我留给你去思考这些是如何结合在一起的。
But, you know, Lawrence Kiermeyer at McGill, he's been doing parallel work for 30 years, building out the cultural psychiatry framework into this serious empirical research program. And Keirmeyer's work on cultural formulation, on the way symptoms get constructed at the interface between cultural narrative and embodied distress, on the way diagnostic categories travel internationally and what they do when they arrive is something that is some of the most important work happening in the field. Just when you put the whole world on the ICD10 or ICD11 and then you start to make them think that way, does that create any problems that weren't there before? That's an interesting question. That could be its own podcast. Even if you solve more problems than you create. Did you create any?
但是，你知道，麦吉尔大学的劳伦斯·基尔迈尔（Lawrence Kirmayer），他30年来一直在做平行工作，将文化精神病学框架构建成这个严肃的实证研究项目。基尔迈尔关于文化表述的工作，关于症状在文化叙事和具身痛苦之间的界面上如何被构建的方式，关于诊断类别如何在国际间传播以及它们到达时会做什么，是该领域正在进行的最重要的工作之一。当你把全世界都纳入ICD-10或ICD-11，然后你开始让他们那样思考时，这会产生以前不存在的问题吗？这是一个有趣的问题。这可以成为它自己的播客。即使你解决的问题比你制造的问题多。你制造了任何问题吗？
Ethan Waters wrote a book in 2010 called Crazy Like Us. That is this popular synthesis of all of this kind of work. And I think that's one of the better books written about American psychiatry that nobody who works in American psychiatry reads. But Waters traces these specific case studies of American diagnostic categories being exported to other cultures. and what happens when they arrive. And that, you know, exportation of American depression to Japan in the late 90s through this coordinated SSRI marketing campaign
伊森·沃特斯（Ethan Waters）在2010年写了一本名为《像我们一样疯狂》（Crazy Like Us）的书。这是所有这类工作的一种通俗综合。我认为这是关于美国精神病学的最好的书之一，但没有一个在美国精神病学工作的人读过它。但沃特斯追踪了美国诊断类别被出口到其他文化的具体案例研究，以及它们到达时会发生什么。而且，你知道，90年代末通过这种协调的SSRI营销活动，将美国抑郁症出口到日本，
that Glaxo Smith Klein ran with the cooperation of Japanese academic psychiatrists is one of the cleaner case studies there. And, you know, Japan in the early 90s did not have much of what we would call depression. Japan had a different framework for what we would consider a similar phenomenon. You know, the pharmaceutical industry, recognized a market opportunity there and they deliberately worked to change Japanese understanding of suffering so that the suffering would become
葛兰素史克（Glaxo Smith Klein）在日本学术精神科医生的配合下开展的活动，是那里比较清晰的案例研究之一。而且，你知道，90年代初的日本并没有多少我们所说的抑郁症。日本对我们认为相似的现象有不同的框架。你知道，制药行业在那里发现了一个市场机会，他们刻意努力改变日本人对痛苦的理解，以便这种痛苦变得
diagnosable as depression and therefore treatable with SSRIs because Japan was a lot more of a private culture you were sort of performative about certain unique things that in America might be private or less public and then you were very private about things that in America might be more public and so the way that the language of diagnosis doesn't fit that You have to change the way that people make private and public space in order to diagnose them because you're taking a checklist that is not understanding these things as a dynamic process, which I would argue, you have to understand them as a dynamic process that is changing and blocked energy and forces. If you're not thinking that way, if you don't have some kind of model that does that, you've killed them. When you have checklist, and this is evidence to my point, when you have checklist and you take them to a different culture and they don't work anymore, that's telling you that the truth's not really in the checklist.
可以被诊断为抑郁症，从而可以用SSRIs治疗。因为日本是一个更私密的文化，你对某些独特的事情表现得很有表演性，而在美国可能是私密的或不那么公开的，然后你对在美国可能更公开的事情非常私密。所以诊断语言不适合这种情况的方式。你必须改变人们创造私人和公共空间的方式才能诊断他们，因为你采用的是一个清单，它没有将这些事情理解为一个动态过程，我认为，你必须将它们理解为一个正在变化的、阻塞的能量和力量的动态过程。如果你不是那样思考的，如果你没有某种能做到这一点的模型，你就扼杀了他们。当你有了清单，这就是我观点的证据，当你有了清单，你把它们带到不同的文化中，它们就不再起作用了，这告诉你真相并不真的在清单里。
right? So within a decade, you know, Japanese depression rates had risen dramatically and antidepressant prescriptions had become routine. And a country that had previously understood suffering through a substantially different cultural framework had been brought into the American framework. And the frameworks in position produced the disease that the framework was designed to treat. And so now it could be treated. So just hold that picture because, you know, we don't want the series on American psychology to leave America too much. But America did become an international model or part of one. So if we were going to go back and say,
对吧？所以十年之内，你知道，日本的抑郁症发病率急剧上升，抗抑郁药处方变得司空见惯。一个以前通过完全不同的文化框架来理解痛苦的国家，被纳入了美国的框架。而框架的强加产生了该框架旨在治疗的疾病。所以现在它可以被治疗了。所以先记住那幅图景，因为，你知道，我们不想让关于美国心理学的系列节目离开美国太多。但美国确实成为了一个国际模型或其中的一部分。所以如果我们回去说，
what if there's a layered model that considers all of these variables? What would it look like? What could it look like? It wasn't a checklist. Because I don't think biology should be discarded. You know, I definitely think that a lot of mental illness, a lot of self has this biological component.
如果有一个考虑所有这些变量的分层模型会怎样？它会是什么样子？它可能是什么样子？它不是一个清单。因为我不认为应该抛弃生物学。你知道，我绝对认为很多精神疾病、很多自我都有这种生物学成分。
I just don't think it can hold all of it, you know, as I'm saying. So if you had a cultural layer that's shaped with the biological layer, expressed, then the biological layer shaped what the cultural layer could develop. And the relational layer shapes both. So the behavioral layer is built out of the interaction of all of these. And the apparatus has been trying for 40 years to identify a single layer that causes all of it. You know, usually looking at neurochemical. And then saying, well, we'll just go ahead and say dopamine disorder and then, you know, the field will catch up, the science will catch up. And then the science has failed to do that.
我只是不认为它能容纳所有这些，你知道，正如我所说的。所以如果你有一个被生物层塑造的文化层，表达出来，那么生物层就塑造了文化层可以发展什么。而关系层塑造了两者。所以行为层是由所有这些的相互作用构建出来的。而体制40年来一直试图确定一个导致所有这一切的单一层。你知道，通常是看神经化学。然后说，好吧，我们直接说是多巴胺紊乱，然后，你知道，这个领域会赶上，科学会赶上。然后科学未能做到这一点。
And I don't think the problem is in any of the directions they tried. I think the problem is in trying to make one single layer that can be screened for and quantified do everything that psychology does, that human psychology is capable of. You know, the disease does not live in any single layer. The disease emerges from the interaction of all of them. And the only instrument that can hold all of those layers at once is a human being who has been trained to do so. If you don't train them to do it and you don't think that those layers exist, then you
我不认为问题在于他们尝试的任何方向。我认为问题在于试图让一个可以被筛选和量化的单一层去做心理学所能做的一切，去做人类心理学有能力做的一切。你知道，疾病并不存在于任何单一层中。疾病产生于所有这些层的相互作用。而唯一能同时容纳所有这些层的仪器，是一个受过训练去这样做的、完整的人。如果你不训练他们去做，而且你不认为这些层存在，那么你
can't see them, no matter how much you spend on research. And the modern apparatus of American psychology fundamentally cannot do this. The protocols cannot do this. Even when, you know, these people at Harvard say that maybe we should. You know, the DSM can't do it. A.I. can't do it. Only a clinician can do this. And the apparatus has been systematically training clinicians to be unable to do this for a long time. Static in the... You say you're fine, but your eyes read... So what is a better apparatus than the one we have?
就看不见它们，无论你在研究上花多少钱。而现代美国心理学体制从根本上做不到这一点。协议做不到这一点。即使当，你知道，哈佛的这些人说也许我们应该这样做。你知道，DSM做不到。人工智能做不到。只有临床医生能做到这一点。而体制长期以来一直在系统地训练临床医生无法做到这一点。静电在……你说你很好，但你的眼睛读出……那么，比我们现有的更好的体制是什么？
Right? Like, is there a better alternative to everything that I've talked about in the series? Because, you know, there's some good things in the system that we have. What direction do you go in? I think all of them. You know, what categories could replace the DSM's categories? Well, my answer would be rethink what category is. You know, the science has been moving and the science is pointing somewhere.
对吧？就像，对于我在本系列中谈到的所有内容，有没有更好的替代方案？因为，你知道，我们现有的系统中也有一些好的东西。你往哪个方向走？我认为所有方向。你知道，什么类别可以取代DSM的类别？嗯，我的回答是重新思考什么是类别。你知道，科学一直在进步，科学正指向某个地方。
So let's look if we tear the silos down, the silos of insecurity. Where is all of the science? Other people's numbers that arguably are better than the ones we've been collecting in American psychology. Where do they point? What's converging across multiple independent lines of work, which I don't have time to talk about all these people. I've got a big blog.
所以让我们看看如果我们拆除筒仓，不安全感的筒仓。所有的科学在哪里？其他人的数字，可以说比我们在美国心理学中收集的那些更好。它们指向哪里？什么在多个独立的工作线中汇聚，我没有时间谈论所有这些人。我有一个大博客。
I've got a podcast, but even half of what we write about, it's not all recorded. And most of what I write is it jumping off. point to you should go read this if you like this consider these perspectives but you know I can't mention all of them but you know there's a picture of psychopathology that I think could be a layered dimensional mechanistic and transdiagnostic model that is probably more useful to the to even the hospital and that's high top you know the hierarchical taxonomy of psychopathology this is a direction that Thomas Nsel even though he talks about the cultural um he's the nymh who dumps the DSM.
我有一个播客，但即使是我们写的一半内容，也没有全部记录下来。而且我写的大部分内容都是一个跳板，如果你喜欢这个，你应该去读读这个，考虑这些观点，但是，你知道，我不能提到所有这些，但是，你知道，有一种精神病理学的图景，我认为可以是一个分层的、维度的、机械的和跨诊断的模型，这可能对医院甚至更有用，那就是HiTOP（精神病理学分层分类法），这是一个托马斯·因塞尔（Thomas Insel）的方向，尽管他谈论文化……他是那个抛弃DSM的NIMH（美国国家心理健康研究所）负责人。
But, you know, he's, he believed in the cultural component of mental illness a lot and the environment. But what he believed in a way that I didn't is that until you understand these things as completely biological in their function in the brain, you can't treat them. So when he was asked about the kind of things that I brought up here, why did he not use high top? Why did he go with RDOK, which was this model that the NIH said, this thing's not going to be done for 10 years.
但是，你知道，他非常相信精神疾病的文化成分和环境。但他相信的方式与我不同，他认为除非你理解这些东西在大脑中的功能是完全生物学的，否则你无法治疗它们。所以当他被问及我在这里提出的这类问题时，为什么他不使用HiTOP？为什么他选择了RDoC（研究领域标准），这是一个NIH说“这东西10年内不会完成”的模型。
Like, it's a decade away from being done. it's already better than what the DSM has been doing for 60. We've lost all faith in this. And so we're going to jump to this unfinished model, RDOC, and use that. So what RDoc tracks is just these sort of objective numbers. And, you know, Insull said something about diabetes one time he said, you know, like mental illness, you know, we know that fast food causes diabetes. But when doctors are treating diabetes, they don't go and then pull like all of the fast food
就像，距离完成还有十年。它已经比DSM 60年来所做的要好了。我们已经失去了对这个的所有信心。所以我们要跳到这个未完成的模型RDoC，并使用它。所以RDoC追踪的只是这些客观数字。而且，你知道，因塞尔有一次谈到糖尿病时说，你知道，像精神疾病一样，你知道，我们知道快餐导致糖尿病。但当医生治疗糖尿病时，他们不会去拉取你所在地区所有的快餐
density in your area. they diagnosed based on the biological mechanism of blood sugar and insulin. And I want those same things for psychiatry or else psychiatry is invalid as a science. Well, then I think, you know, again, I don't know, maybe a hundred more years of research in the direction that we've been going, you'll find the biological causes for all of these things. I don't think we ever will. I think that what the deep brain is doing is pretty context dependent, pretty complicated, and that you probably can never treat something like depression in the same
密度。他们根据血糖和胰岛素的生物学机制进行诊断。我希望精神病学也有同样的东西，否则精神病学作为一门科学是无效的。好吧，那么我想，你知道，再次强调，我不知道，也许再研究一百年我们一直走的方向，你会找到所有这些东西的生物学原因。我不认为我们永远会。我认为深层大脑正在做的事情是非常依赖情境的，非常复杂的，而且你可能永远无法以治疗糖尿病的相同方式去治疗像抑郁症这样的东西。抱歉。再说一次，也许我错了。但那么他为什么选择不往HiTOP的方向走呢？我的意思是，它就是那样。他基本上说，如果精神病学，即使文化和环境影响科学，如果科学不能归结为生物学中的数字，那么它就不是真正的科学。我不认为那个观点是正确的。所以，你知道，HiTOP的人，精神病理学分层分类法，他们建立了这个非常有趣的模型，20年了。它是经验性的，是从下往上构建的。他们从庞大的人群中获取观察到的症状，并观察这些症状在真实人类中如何在彼此的情境中实际变化。他们产生了一个结构。所以你看到了这些有趣的联系
way that you can treat diabetes. Sorry. And again, maybe I'm wrong. But so why did he choose not to go in the direction of high top? I mean, that's what it is. He said basically if psychiatry, even though in culture and environment influence the science, if the science can't be boiled down to numbers in the biology, then it's not really a real science. And I don't think that perspective is right. So, you know, the high top people, the hierarchical taxonomy of psychopathology, they have built this really interesting model 20 years. It's empirical and it's from the bottom up. They take observed symptoms across enormous populations and they look at how the symptoms actually vary in the context of each other in real human beings. And they produce a structure. So you see these interesting relationships
当你以那种方式看待诊断时，症状之间存在着你以前从未真正看到过的联系。你知道，不是由一个委员会强加的结构，委员会只是说这就是诊断，现在让我们去寻找症状，而是一个从数据中产生的结构。你获取所有数据，然后让它告诉你诊断是什么。你查看那个人说的正在发生的所有问题，这些问题是一个问题，然后你查看这些问题如何与可能或可能不是你想作为类别治疗并关注的诊断的其他问题表现出关系。所以有一个内化谱系，有一个外化谱系。所以有一个思维障碍谱系，有一个躯体形式谱系。有一个疏离
between symptoms when you look at diagnosis that way that you wouldn't have ever really seen before. You know, not a structure imposed by a committee that just says this is the diagnosis, now let's go find the symptoms, but it's a structure that emerges from data. You get all of the data and then you let it tell you what the diagnoses are. You look at every single thing that the person says is going on that's a problem and then you look at how those problems are all showing up in relationship to other problems that may or may not be a diagnosis that you might want to treat as a category and pay attention to. So there's an internalizing spectrum and there's an externalizing spectrum. So there's a thought disorder spectrum and there's a somatoformed spectrum. There's a detachment
谱系。而在所有这些之上，有一个东西叫P因子。HiTOP中的P因子是精神病理学脆弱性的一般维度。你有多容易出现症状？让我们看看风险因素，以及这些风险因素使什么样的事情变得更明显。其中一些是基因。其中一些是环境。所以你可以通过仅仅查看数据来看穿所有这些层，这就像，嘿，你一直要求一个数字，对吧？这是很多数字。看起来你的忠诚不是对数字。而是对当前机构需要数字来维持运作的不安全感，
spectrum. And above all of those, there's something called the P factor. And the P factor in high top is the general dimension of vulnerability to psychopathology. How vulnerable are you to having symptoms at all? And let's look at risk factors and what kind of things those risk factors make more present. Some of that's going to be genes. Some of it's going to be environment. So you can sort of see through all of these layers by just looking at the data, which it's like, hey, you keep asking for a number, right? This is a lot of numbers. It looks like your allegiance is not to numbers. It's to the insecurity of the way that the current establishments need numbers to run the show,
我认为这不是一个非常科学的项目。所以，你知道，因塞尔在2013年引入的RDoC框架，然后，你知道，他连同他的转型诊断演讲，一直指向一个平行的方向。你知道，RDoC说，让我们停止假装我们知道什么是精神分裂症、抑郁症和焦虑症。我认为HiTOP稍微好一点的地方在于，当你观察脆弱性本身时，你知道，可能有一位患有重度抑郁症的父母。
which I would say is not a very scientific project. So, you know, the Ardoc framework, which Encel introduced in 2013, and then, you know, he alongside his transforming diagnosis, you know, speech, has been pointing in a parallel direction. You know, Ardoch says, let's stop pretending that we know what schizophrenia and depressive. and anxiety are. Where I think high top is a little bit better is that when you're looking at vulnerability itself, you know, there may be a parent with a major depressive disorder.
这并没有真正增加他们的孩子患重度抑郁症的几率很多。不过，他们确实增加了他们的孩子患某种疾病的几率。所以那是什么取决于一千个其他因素，体制40年来一直积极地训练自己不去关注这些因素。你可以看看也许对，你知道，病态关系的倾向，或者对宗教组织的病态关系，或者也许其中一些东西不是遗传的，但与他们一起长大的父母有一个孩子，更有可能患有
And it is not really increasing the odds that their child has major depressive disorder by very much. They are increasing the odds that their child has something, though. So what that something is depends on a thousand other factors, that the apparatus has been actively training itself not to, attend to for 40 years. You could look at maybe a propensity to, you know, pathological relationships or pathological relationship to a religious organization or how maybe some of these things aren't genetic, but the parent who grows up with them has a child that is more likely to have
基于他们的遗传障碍的人格障碍。我的意思是，你可以看到和理解各种各样的事情，以便看到，你知道，我们是如何运作的。所以，你知道，RDoC并没有真正实现因塞尔承诺的一切。我们已经使用它一段时间了。现在差不多完成了。我想诚实地，你知道，谈谈这一点，特别是因为我不喜欢它。但RDoC过于还原论、过于关注回路、过于轻视心理和社会因素的批评，在它发布时是一个公平的批评。但RDoC产生的东西，即使它在开始时跌跌撞撞，也产生了一代不再相信的年轻研究人员。
a personality disorder based on their genetic disorder. I mean, there's all sorts of things that you could see and understand in order to see, you know, how we function. So, You know, Ardoch has not really delivered everything that didn't sell promised. And we've had it for a while. It's about done now. And I want to be honest, you know, about that, especially because I don't love it. But the criticism that Ardoch was too reductionist, to circuit focus, too dismissive of the psychological and the social, was a fair criticism when it was unveiled. But what Ardoch produced, even as it stumbled at the beginning, has been this generation of researchers who stopped believing.
所有那些DSM的东西。当他们远离那些类别时，他们发现了一些有趣的事情。其中之一是精神病理学的网络理论，丹尼·博斯布姆（Denny Boersboom）和他的合作者一直在发展它。他们走进了这第三个方向。他们停止寻找症状背后的潜在疾病。他们说症状就是障碍。所以症状在因果上相互激活。失眠导致疲劳。
All of that DSM stuff. and they've discovered some interesting things when they moved away from those categories. So one of them is the network theory of psychopathology, which Denny Boersboom and his collaborators have been developing. And they kind of went in this third direction. They stopped looking for the latent disease beneath the symptoms. And they're saying that the symptoms are the disorder. So the symptoms causally activate each other. And insomnia produces fatigue.
所有那些DSM相关的东西。当他们不再局限于这些分类时，发现了一些有趣的事情。其中之一就是由Denny Boersboom及其合作者开发的心理病理学网络理论。他们选择了第三种方向。他们不再寻找症状背后的潜在疾病，而是认为症状本身就是障碍。也就是说，症状之间存在因果激活关系，比如失眠会导致疲劳。
And that produces concentration. problems, and that produces failure at work, and that produces shame, and that produces low mood, and that produces insomnia. And then that produces a changing self-image that on a long enough timeline could become semi-permanent. And the disorder is not under the symptoms. The disorder is in the loop, the symptoms form. So if you view these things as living, interdependent processes interacting with
这会导致注意力问题，导致工作失败，导致羞耻感，导致情绪低落，导致失眠。进而导致自我形象的改变，在足够长的时间跨度下，这种改变可能会变得半永久。障碍并不存在于症状之下，障碍存在于症状形成的循环之中。因此，如果你将这些事物视为相互依存、相互作用的生命过程，
each other, I think you're going in a better direction, which this one is. And, you know, the leverage point and the treatment is not the imaginary disease underneath. It's the bridge, the symptoms, you know, connect and loop against each other. And the nodes, if you intervene in them, you can collapse the whole network back into a non-pathological state, which this would be harder. It would mean that a lot of people have been doing it the wrong way, which I think is the reason that we haven't moved to something better, is that we just keep clinging to the life raft that we're in because it's the one that we got. And even though we know there's better things out there, it'd be a risk to get to them. Some people may not make it or might not be able to. But hey, you're not dying.
我认为你正朝着更好的方向前进，而这正是目前的情况。你知道，杠杆点和治疗方法不是其下方的虚构疾病，而是桥梁，是症状，你知道，它们相互连接并形成循环。如果你干预这些节点，你就能将整个网络坍缩回非病理状态，但这会更难。这意味着许多人一直以来都做错了，我认为这就是我们没有转向更好事物的原因，我们只是紧紧抓住我们所在的救生筏，因为这是我们仅有的。尽管我们知道外面有更好的东西，但去获取它们是一种风险。有些人可能无法成功，或者可能无法做到。但嘿，你又不会死。
You're just not able to continue to practice psychotherapy the way that you think it should be practiced in a way that I would say is wrong. So, you know, it's not as bad as swimming, you know, to another ship. It's just, you know, just that thing. But anyway, this explains, you know, comorbidity in a way that the categorical model can't, really. You know, the comorbidity is not two separate diseases. co-occurring. It's this natural propagation of symptoms activating across this bridge that connects different symptoms. And most people that have one symptom might have another, but other people may form a different bridge that is still related to the symptom, but more rare. And the way that that
你只是无法继续以你认为应该实践的方式实践心理治疗，而我称之为错误的方式。所以，你知道，这并不像游向另一艘船那么糟糕。这只是，你知道，就是那样。但无论如何，这解释了，你知道，共病现象，这是分类模型无法真正做到的。你知道，共病不是两种独立的疾病同时发生。这是症状在连接不同症状的桥梁上激活的自然传播。大多数有一种症状的人可能还有另一种症状，但其他人可能会形成一种与该症状相关但更罕见的桥梁。而这种方式
could treat something like depression, something like addiction, you know, which addiction is comorbid with a whole lot of different, you're likely to have a lot of other disorders if you have issues with addiction, but you don't necessarily have all of them and some people have none of them. That is a more useful model. So if you look at, when I mentioned Carl Fristin before, you know, he has this idea, the free energy principle. And it is a mode of analyzing predictive processing. And, you know, the framework that grows up around that gives us this unifying language
可以治疗像抑郁症、成瘾症这样的问题，你知道，成瘾症与许多不同的疾病共病，如果你有成瘾问题，你很可能还有很多其他障碍，但你不一定全部都有，有些人则一个都没有。这是一个更有用的模型。所以如果你看看，当我之前提到卡尔·弗里斯顿时，你知道，他有这个想法，自由能原理。这是一种分析预测处理的模式。而且，你知道，围绕它建立的框架为我们提供了一种统一的语言，
across all of these converging lines. The free energy principle says that the brain is fundamentally a prediction machine. And the brain maintains this internal generative model of the world. And the model is hierarchical. High level priors come down from the top of the hierarchy. Shaping with the lower levels are allowed to perceive. And so allowed. It filters out information that is too against our ideals,
跨越所有这些汇聚的路线。自由能原理认为大脑本质上是一台预测机器。大脑维持着这个关于世界的内部生成模型。而且这个模型是分层的。高层先验从层级顶部向下传递。塑造下层被允许感知的内容。因此，它过滤掉了那些太违背我们理想的信息，
too against our ego, even evidence that you're giving the patient that the way that they're acting is not correct or consistent with their own values. That can be removed. You know, so sensory evidence comes up from the bottom, comparing against what the prior is expected, and then generating a prediction. And sometimes there's an error in that prediction when the sensory evidence doesn't match. So the whole architecture is organized around minimizing prediction error. It wants to make sure that it doesn't encounter something that it didn't think would be there.
太违背我们自我的信息，甚至是你在向患者提供的证据，表明他们的行为方式是不正确的，或者与他们自己的价值观不一致。这些都可以被移除。你知道，所以感官证据从底部上升，与先验预期的内容进行比较，然后生成预测。有时当感官证据不匹配时，预测会出现错误。所以整个架构是围绕最小化预测误差来组织的。它想确保它不会遇到它认为不会出现在那里的东西。
And Fristin calls that minimizing free energy. So the brain wants its predictions to come true because predictions that come true, the model is accurate. And an accurate model means the organism can act in the world successfully. It becomes pathological when we start pretending that our predictions are accurate, even though they aren't. Because the reward system of, you know, getting that prediction correct becomes more pleasurable than actually being effective in surviving as an organism, right? You know, the brain creates something outside itself there. So there's this critical. variable in the Friston system, which is precision weighting. You know, the brain is constantly
弗里斯顿称之为最小化自由能。所以大脑希望它的预测成真，因为成真的预测意味着模型是准确的。而准确的模型意味着有机体可以在世界上成功地行动。当我们开始假装我们的预测是准确的，尽管它们并非如此时，它就变得病态了。因为获得正确预测的奖励系统，你知道，变得比作为有机体在生存中实际有效更令人愉悦，对吧？你知道，大脑在那里创造了自身之外的东西。所以弗里斯顿系统中有一个关键变量，那就是精度加权。你知道，大脑一直在
deciding how much confidence to put in its priors versus how much confidence to put in incoming sensory evidence. And so if the priors are weighted heavily and the sensory evidence is weighted lightly, the brain ignores contradictory evidence and it stays committed to its existing model. If the priors are weighted lightly and the sensory evidence is weighted heavily, then the brain updates its model rapidly in response to whatever it encounters. And the balance between top-down prior weighting and bottom-up evidence weighting is set by neurotransmitter systems, by attention, by emotional states, by cultural training, by every layer of the system at once. And here is the move that makes the framework so powerful for psychiatry. Every major psychiatric
决定对先验赋予多少信心，以及对传入的感官证据赋予多少信心。因此，如果先验被赋予了很高的权重，而感官证据被赋予了很低的权重，大脑就会忽略矛盾的证据，并保持对现有模型的承诺。如果先验被赋予了较低的权重，而感官证据被赋予了较高的权重，那么大脑就会根据它遇到的任何情况迅速更新其模型。自上而下的先验加权和自下而上的证据加权之间的平衡是由神经递质系统、注意力、情绪状态、文化训练以及系统的每一层同时设定的。这就是使该框架对精神病学如此强大的举措。每一个主要的精神病学
phenomenon can be reframed as a specific computational failure of the prediction error machine, and with a specific signature in terms of how the precision weighting has gone wrong. So that's pretty useful for something like a personality disorder. That's very useful for something like schizophrenia, a delusion or a hallucination. When you're looking at a model instead of just, is the symptom there or not? What was the gene that made it be there? What's the biological reason? Well, that's biology and its numbers, but it also isn't as simple as American psychology wants the numbers to be. So psychosis is the classical predictive processing account of, you know, Psychosis like schizophrenia involves underweighting high-level priors and
现象都可以被重新定义为预测误差机器的特定计算失败，并且在精度加权出错的方式上具有特定的特征。所以这对像人格障碍这样的东西非常有用。这对像精神分裂症、妄想或幻觉这样的东西非常有用。当你观察一个模型而不是仅仅看症状是否存在？是什么基因导致了它的存在？生物学原因是什么？嗯，那是生物学及其数字，但它也不像美国心理学希望数字那样简单。所以精神病是预测处理的经典解释，你知道，像精神分裂症这样的精神病涉及对高层先验的权重不足和
overweaving low-level prediction errors. So the brain stops trusting its model of the world. Every minor sensory anomaly generates a strong prediction error that determines explanation. So the brain scrambling to explain this cascade of unexpected events generates new high-level beliefs to account for them. And the new beliefs are not constrained by the previous model because the previous model has lost its precision. So the explanations become bizarre, but they feel true.
对低层预测误差的权重过高。所以大脑停止信任其世界模型。每一个微小的感官异常都会产生一个强烈的预测误差，从而决定解释。因此，大脑为了解释这一连串意想不到的事件而手忙脚乱，产生了新的高层信念来解释它们。而新的信念不受先前模型的约束，因为先前模型已经失去了其精度。所以解释变得离奇，但它们感觉是真实的。
Delusions. They form not because the brain is broken in some random way, but because the prediction error machinery is doing exactly what it's supposed to do, except that the precision weighting is set in a way that produces a runaway cascade of error correction. So hallucinations in this framework are something slightly different. You know, there are cases where high-level priors break through and become perceptually vivid where the brain's internally generated predictions get treated as if they were external sensory events.
妄想。它们的形成不是因为大脑以某种随机方式损坏了，而是因为预测误差机制正在做它应该做的事情，只是精度加权的设置方式产生了一连串失控的错误修正。所以在这个框架中，幻觉是稍微不同的东西。你知道，在某些情况下，高层先验突破并变得在感知上生动，大脑内部生成的预测被当作外部感官事件来对待。
And the model predicts the voice. And because the precision weighting has gone wrong, the prediction is experienced as perception. So the brain literally loses the ability to tell the difference between what is outside of it and what it is making up. And then what is making up becomes more real. Then what is outside.
模型预测了声音。由于精度加权出了问题，预测被体验为感知。所以大脑实际上失去了区分外部事物和它编造的事物之间的能力。然后它编造的东西变得比外部的东西更真实。
And I stop making sense to other people, but I still feel completely right. to myself in a way that you can't talk me out of in a way that it kind of isn't wrong because usually I'm making some sort of metaphor based on information that was true at some point but I've lost the sense of kind of time updating and context now you know hold this next to and this would explain why CBT for psychosis and schizophrenia which there is a manual for that I read and I thought it sounded crazy and tried to use it once in the hospital and said, yep, this does not work.
我不再对其他人有意义，但我对自己仍然感觉完全正确，以至于你无法说服我，而且在某种程度上它并不错误，因为通常我是在基于在某个时间点是真实的信息进行某种隐喻，但我已经失去了那种时间更新和语境的感觉，现在你知道，把这个放在旁边，这将解释为什么针对精神病和精神分裂症的CBT（认知行为疗法），我读过一本手册，我觉得它听起来很疯狂，在医院里试过一次，然后说，是的，这行不通。
But it would explain why something like that does not work. You know, the American patients in, you know, San Mateo from Lerman's research, the, you know, foreign, violent, intrusive voices, the Ghanaian patients in Acra. And, you know, the Fristin framework, if you take that with the Lerman stuff, you know, it would predict everything the same. The brain generates voices based on the high-level priors it's been trained on. If the high-level priors are the American medicalized framework where voices indicate disease and a foreign agent has invaded the clean self, then the brain generates voices that have those properties. If the high-level priors are the Ghanian spiritual framework where the direct address from divine beings is part of how the world works, then the brain generates voices that have those properties.
但这将解释为什么像这样的东西行不通。你知道，勒曼研究中圣马特奥的美国患者，你知道，外国的、暴力的、侵入性的声音，阿克拉的加纳患者。而且，你知道，弗里斯顿框架，如果你把它和勒曼的东西结合起来，你知道，它会预测出同样的一切。大脑根据它所受训练的高层先验生成声音。如果高层先验是美国医学化的框架，即声音表明疾病并且外国代理人入侵了纯净的自我，那么大脑就会生成具有这些属性的声音。如果高层先验是加纳的精神框架，即来自神圣存在的直接对话是世界运作方式的一部分，那么大脑就会生成具有这些属性的声音。
And so the neurological capacity is the same. The precision weighting failure is the same. The cultural priors that shape what the failure produces are different, and that does. difference becomes enormous. You know, autism. The autism story in predictive processing is the computational inverse of psychosis. Autistic brains may have underweighted high-level priors and overweighted attention to low-level sensory detail. So sensory information that the neurotypical brain filters out as a relevant noise gets through to consciousness with the autistic brain. And the autistic brain cannot rely on its priors to predict away the buzzing of the fluorescent light,
所以神经学能力是一样的。精度加权失败是一样的。塑造失败产生什么的文化先验是不同的，而这种差异变得巨大。你知道，自闭症。预测处理中的自闭症故事是精神病的计算逆过程。自闭症大脑可能对高层先验的权重不足，而对低层感官细节的注意力权重过高。所以神经典型大脑过滤掉的作为相关噪音的感官信息，在自闭症大脑中进入了意识。而自闭症大脑无法依靠其先验来预测掉荧光灯的嗡嗡声，
the texture of the shirt of the collar, you know, the the slightly off pitch in the speaker's voice, every detail becomes salient and overwhelming sometimes. And so every change is a prediction error. And then the world is overwhelmingly informative. And the behavioral signatures of autism, the preference for sameness, routine, the restricted interest, they're the brain's compensatory strategies for managing a sensory environment that has not been pre-organized by sufficient prior waiting. Depression. You know, depression at a predictive process is something like locked in pessimistic priors with low precision on positive prediction errors.
衣领的质地，你知道，说话者声音中稍微走调的地方，每一个细节都变得显著，有时令人不知所措。所以每一个变化都是一个预测误差。然后世界变得极其丰富。而自闭症的行为特征，对相同性、常规的偏好，受限的兴趣，它们是大脑管理一个没有被足够的先验加权预先组织好的感官环境的补偿策略。抑郁症。你知道，预测过程中的抑郁症就像是锁定的悲观先验，对积极预测误差的精度较低。
You know, the brain is built up this model in which nothing will work. Hope is never justified what IFS would call a protective part that wants you to be hopeless because you've learned that all hope is just effort that is wasted. And the model is then defended against the contradicting evidence by reducing the precision waiting on any prediction error that would update the model in a positive. direction and so the depressed person walks past beauty and does not see it and it's not just an intellectual process right like there are somatic markers in these things too so it's I don't want to budget any energy at all I don't want to budget any hope I don't want to budget any feeling creativity it's these unconscious like an emotional somatic things it's not just the kind of intellectual things that I can read to you
你知道，大脑建立了一个模型，在这个模型中什么都不会奏效。希望永远是不合理的，IFS（内在家庭系统疗法）称之为保护性部分，它希望你感到绝望，因为你已经了解到所有的希望都只是浪费的努力。然后模型通过降低对任何会以积极方向更新模型的预测误差的精度加权，来防御矛盾的证据，所以抑郁的人走过美景却看不见它，这不仅仅是一个智力过程，对吧，这些事情中也有躯体标记，所以它是，我根本不想预算任何能量，我不想预算任何希望，我不想预算任何感觉、创造力，这些是无意识的，像情感躯体一样的东西，它不仅仅是我可以读给你的那种智力上的东西，
it's the entire body deciding the world is hopeless you know anxiety trauma these explain quite a bit in a way that I think the the checkboxes of the DSM don't and the thoughts leave to beliefs which lead their beliefs lead to thoughts lead to behaviors thing of CBT you know kind of can't get and so the clinical implication of the predictive processing framework is is pretty big because every model of psychotherapy can be reframed as a specific intervention on the precision weighting of the prior structure of the brain so CBT and the manualized institutional version of it intervenes at this explicit level of cognitive priors,
这是整个身体决定世界是绝望的，你知道，焦虑、创伤，这些解释了很多，以一种我认为DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）的复选框无法做到的方式，以及CBT的“思想导致信念，信念导致思想，思想导致行为”的东西，你知道，有点无法理解。所以预测处理框架的临床意义相当大，因为每一种心理治疗模型都可以被重新定义为对大脑先验结构的精度加权的特定干预，所以CBT及其手册化的制度版本在认知先验的这个明确层面上进行干预，
asking the patient to challenge the high-level beliefs and then update them. So CBT works, but when it works, it works because explicit cognitive priors are real and can be updated. CBT fails and gaslights people when it tells them that their cognitive faculties have power over parts of the brain that cognitive faculties don't. You know, when it fails, it fails because much of the relevant prior structure is not explicit. It's not accessible to verbal challenge. It is encoded in autonomic and semantic relational layers that the cognitive intervention cannot reach. Behavioral activation works because it generates enough prediction error to shift priors even when verbal challenge can't. You know, exposure therapy works because it generates enough prediction error on the trauma
要求患者挑战高层信念，然后更新它们。所以CBT有效，但当它有效时，它有效是因为明确的认知先验是真实的并且可以被更新。当CBT告诉患者他们的认知能力对大脑中认知能力无法触及的部分拥有权力时，它就会失败并对人们进行煤气灯操纵。你知道，当它失败时，它失败是因为许多相关的先验结构不是明确的。它们无法通过语言挑战来访问。它们被编码在认知干预无法触及的自主和语义关系层中。行为激活有效，因为它产生了足够的预测误差来改变先验，即使语言挑战无法做到。你知道，暴露疗法有效，因为它在创伤先验没有预测到的语境中对创伤先验产生了足够的预测误差，从而允许先验更新。你知道，像EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）和脑点疗法（Brainspotting），我的行业对此相当敌视，你知道，它们通过直接访问精度加权机制来工作，跳过了CBT试图摆弄的那些认知层，这就是为什么CBT的人不理解它。他们会说，眼睛怎么能导致思想？嗯，这是因为你在与身体硬件的不同层面交谈，至少理论上是这样。躯体体验疗法通过访问自主先验来工作，
prior in a context that the trauma prior did not predict to allow the prior to update. You know, something like EMDR and brain spotting, which my industry is pretty hostile to, you know, they work by accessing the precision weighting machinery directly, skipping those cognitive layers that CBT is trying to mess around with, which is why the CBT people don't get it. They're like, how could an eye lead to a thought? Well, it's because you're talking to the body a different level of the hardware, at least as the, you know, the theory goes. Semantic experiencing works by accessing the autonomic priors,
身体自身的预测机制，并允许它释放和重新调节。你知道，IFS工作得稍微深一点。它比认知和行为疗法更是一种深度疗法，因为它通过激活大脑先验结构的多元性来工作，就像是，是的，这是一个结构，但还有许多其他结构，而且还有一个结构制造机制。你知道，从不同的角度对部分及其关系进行重新协商，迷幻疗法也会干扰这个过程。我认为如果临床心理学对弗里斯顿给予更多关注，有很多事情是可以解释的，但他们没有。
the body's own prediction machinery and allowing it to discharge and re-regulate. You know, IFS works a little bit deeper. It's more of a depth therapy than cognitive and behavioral therapy because it works by activating the multiplicity of the brain's prior structure, being like, yes, this is one structure, but there are many others, and there is also a structure-making mechanism. You know, the parts and renegotiation of their relationship from a different vantage point, psychedelic therapy also would mess with this process. There's a lot of things that I think if clinical psychology paid more attention to Friston would be explained, but they don't.
所以为什么不呢？对吧？他很有趣。为什么不呢？所以为什么要抵制现在就抛弃DSM并完全使用高层（HiTOP）的诱惑，你知道，如果它更好并且解释了所有这些不同层面的认知？好吧，让我们给每个患者一个维度概况。让我们运行RDoC（研究领域标准）矩阵。
So why not? Right? He's interesting. Why not? So why resist the temptation to just throw out the DSM now and then use high top completely, you know, if it's better and it accounts for all these different kind of layers of cognition? Well, let's give every patient a dimensional profile. Let's run R-Dog matrices.
让我们计算他们个性化的桥梁症状网络。让我们测量他们的HRV（心率变异性）和自主神经灵活性。让我们做一个炎症面板。让我们做QEEG（定量脑电图）亚型分析。让我们获得多基因风险评分。让我们计算他们跨越所有八层的分层概况，并在最后得出结论。你知道，这比DSM曾经产生的任何诊断文件都要准确得多。然后让我们为该文件向保险公司开账单。
Let's compute their personalized network of bridge symptoms. Let's measure their HRV and their autonomic flexibility. Let's get an inflammatory panel. Let's do QEG subtyping. Let's get a polygenic risk score. Let's compute their layered profile across all eight layers and produce at the end of it. You know, this is much more accurate diagnostic document than the DSM ever produced. And then let's bill insurance for that document.
然后让我们在CPT（现行程序术语）中设置新的代码，以便我们知道如何称呼这些新类别，保险公司可以理解，然后让我们在新的框架中培训临床医生，然后让我们建立新科学所要求的新装置。这是一个相当大的提升。你知道，这是一个相当大的要求。你知道，我想争辩说这是这一集的核心。你知道，这正是错误的举措。而它之所以错误，原因与最初的DSM是错误举措的原因相同。因为科学还没有完成。
and then let us get new code set in CPT so that we know how to call these new categories something insurance can understand, and then let's train clinicians in the new framework, and then let us build the new apparatus that the new science demands. That's a pretty big lift. You know, that's a pretty big ask. You know, I want to argue that this is the heart of the episode. You know, this is the exact wrong move. And the reason it's wrong is the same reason that the original DSM was the wrong move. Because the science isn't done.
科学不会完成。科学现在在2026年正以该领域历史上最快的速度发展。最近有一些监管方面的事情和资金削减，使其朝着非常奇怪的方向发展，同时也丢失了一些它正在收集的信息。但让我们假设如果科学继续发展，通常它在这个领域发展得更快，因为技术变得更好。但无论你在2026年建立什么装置来捕捉当前的科学状态，该装置到2031年都将过时。
The science is not going to be done. the science is right now in 20206 moving faster than at any point in the history of the field. There's some recent regulatory things and defunding that's making it move in really weird directions and then also losing some of the information that it was collecting. But let's just assume that if science was to keep moving, generally it moves faster in this area because technology gets better. But whatever apparatus you build in 2026 to capture the current state of science, that apparatus will be obsolete by 2031.
而高层结构（HiTOP）将被完善，RDoC矩阵将被修订，网络参数将被更新，分层模型将增加更多的层。你知道，一些现有的层最终会被证明是我们意识到实际上并非我们所想的那样的人工制品。它们是，你知道，与别的东西相关的东西。你知道，所以你建立的任何装置在它发布的那一刻起就会开始老化。这就是官僚机构的运作方式。而装置知道这一点。
and the high top structure will get refined and the RDoc matrix will get revised and the network parameters will get updated and the layered model will get more layers. You know, some of the existing layers will turn out to be artifacts that we realize weren't actually what we thought they were. They're, you know, something related to something else. You know, so any apparatus you build will start aging the moment that it ships. That's just how bureaucracy works. And the apparatus knows that.
而这就是我们应该意识到的事情，因为，你知道，美国精神医学学会（APA）一直在2024年和2025年以及2026年发布一种叫做DSM-6路线图的东西，一系列立场文件和工作组报告，以及，你知道，咨询文件，列出了手册的下一个版本应该是什么样子以及它应该如何开发。如果你阅读路线图，你会发现一些非常有趣的东西，你可能不会期望从发布DSM-4和5的同一个机构那里得到。路线图现在在重要领域承认这种基本批评是正确的。它承认分类模型存在有效性问题。
And that is the thing that we should be aware of because, you know, the APA has been publishing across 2024 and 2025 and in 2026 something called the DSM6 roadmap, a series of position papers and a working group reports and, you know, consultation documents laying out what the next edition of the manual is supposed to look like and how it's supposed to be developed. And if you read the roadmap, you find some really interesting stuff that you maybe would not I've expected from the same institution that published the DSM 4 and 5. The roadmap concedes in significant areas now that this basic critique is right. It acknowledges that the categorical model has validity problems.
这只花了45年，对吧？而且它承认像HiTOP这样的维度模型产生了更好的经验结构。而且它承认该装置一直承诺的生物学普遍性从未到来。所以这看起来批评者终于被允许进入对话了，而该装置在这一点上已经向理性承认了这一点，你知道，巨大的经验点。但随后路线图宣布了一个多年过程，将这些批评纳入下一本手册，包括工作组、咨询和现场试验，出版目标在2030年代初的某个时候，但，你知道，可能会有变化。
It only took 45 years, right? And it acknowledges that the dimensional model like ITOP has produced better empirical structures. And it acknowledges that the biological universalism that the apparatus has been promising has never come. So it might look like the critics have finally been admitted to the conversation, and the apparatus has conceded this, you know, vastly at this point, empirical point to reason. But then the roadmap announces a multi-year process to incorporate those critiques into the next manual with working groups and consultations and field trials and a publication target somewhere in the early 2030s, but, you know, subject to change.
所以我将在下一集中花大量时间讨论DSM路线图，我认为它实际上在做什么。但我认为这是一个防御性举措，因为他们不想让这个东西改变。他们宁愿在那艘船上沉没，也不愿加入另一艘船或游向另一艘船。但我现在想把它摆在桌面上，因为这是我所做的结构性论点的证据。该装置无法通过更好的装置来改革。即使当装置本身同意当前的装置是错误的时候，即使当装置邀请批评者进入房间帮助编写下一个版本的时候。该装置在这一点上已经进化出了一种非常复杂的防御机制，
So I'm going to spend serious time on, what the DSM roadmap, what I think it's actually doing in the next episode. But I think this is a defensive move because they don't want this thing to change. They would rather sink on that ship than join another one or swim to another one. But I want it on the table now because it's proof of the structural argument that I'm making. The apparatus cannot be reformed by a better apparatus. Even when the apparatus itself agrees that the current apparatus is wrong, even when the apparatus invites the critics into the room to help write the next version. The apparatus has at this point evolved a defense mechanism that's very sophisticated,
它可以通过发布深思熟虑的文件来吸收自己的批评者，承认他们的批评，以便不改变。并继续像以前一样运作，同时将整整一代人的改革能量引导到一个官僚过程中，该过程最终会结束，但只是需要一点点地推进，因为任何可能在地面上产生实质性不同的大型新变革在任何时候都是不合理的。这听起来像美国的心理学还是政治？你知道，陷阱是承认而不改变。陷阱是该装置说，就像美国对嬉皮士说的那样，就像美国对千禧一代说的那样，就像美国对X世代说的那样，你知道，这是一个为期10年的工作组来解决你的正确性。而计费代码没有改变，培训计划没有改变，被捕获的测量基础设施没有改变。你应该仍然知道我们看到了你，我们感受到了你，让那种在你和官僚机构之间的情感联系通过将其炼金术转化为我反射回给你的情感能量来消散你对变革的需求。这听起来像一个大型语言模型吗？因为如果你抱怨某事，这就是大型语言模型会做的事情。
that it can absorb its own critics by publishing thoughtful documents, acknowledging their critiques, in order to not change. And continuing to operate exactly as it has been operating while channeling the reform energy of an entire generation into a bureaucratic process that will conclude eventually, but just incrementally needs to eke along because any big, new change that might make something materially different on the ground is just not reasonable at any point ever. Does that sound like psychology or politics in America? You know, the trap is the acknowledgement without the change. The trap is the apparatus saying, like America said to the
我不知道有没有人看过电影《阿凡达》，但我称之为官僚举措，即官僚机构说，见鬼，我们不会那样做，但我们不能告诉你，因为有大量的能量要求我们改变，你会做什么，他们左右为难。你会看到一个政客做《阿凡达》里的事情，
hippies, like America said to the millennials, like America said to the Gen X, like, you know, here is a 10-year working group to address your rightness. While the billing code, do not change and the training programs do not change and the captured measurement infrastructure does not change. You should still know that we see you and we feel you and let that emotional connection between you and the bureaucracy dissipate your requirements for change by alchemizing it into an emotional energy that I'm reflecting back at you. Does that sound like a large language model? because if you complain about something, that's what a large language model will do.
他们说，我看见你了，我感受到了你，杰克·萨利。然后他们什么都不做，而群体实际上想要的是。他们只是想确保，你知道，你感到被听到了。你知道，内部的改革是由该装置本身策划的，作为对实际改革的防御。而结构性论点是，没有任何装置可以解决这个问题，包括目前正在邀请改革者帮助解决它的装置，因为正在进行修复的装置就是问题所在。而且它总是参与其中的。
And I don't know if anyone's seen the movie Avatar, but what I call the bureaucratic move, where bureaucracy says, hell no, we're not going to do that, but we can't tell you that because there's a whole lot of energy asking us to change, what you'll do, and they do this right and left. You will see a politician do the thing from Avatar,
在它自己的设计中，它参与了自己的改革。而在内心深处，它知道这是如何运作的。做这项工作的人也知道。但他们不能知道他们知道。就像治疗中参与自己症状的患者一样。这就是我想让你追踪的举措。前沿移动得太快，任何装置都无法捕捉。
where they say, I see you, I feel you, Jake Salih. and then they don't do anything that the group is actually wanting. They just want to make sure that, you know, you feel heard. You know, the reform within is being staged by the apparatus itself as a defense against actual reform. And the structural argument is that no apparatus can fix this, including the apparatus that is currently inviting reformers to help fix it, because the apparatus that is doing the fixing is the problem. And it is always participatory.
而这正是这一刻与精神病学史上任何先前时刻真正不同的地方。我们不需要更好的手册。我们需要停止假装手册是正确的工具。因为能够跟上快速移动前沿的工具不是手册。
in its own reform by its own design. And deep down, it knows how that works. And so do the people who are doing the working. But they can't know that. They can't let themselves know that they know. Just like a patient in therapy that's participating in their own symptom. And that's the move I want you to track. The frontier is moving too fast for any apparatus to capture.
那个工具是一个知情的人类。而且这个工具不仅仅是在需要有人提供不是AI的协议的琐碎意义上的人类。这个工具是在强意义上的人类，即工作的活跃变量本质上是无法追踪的。只有人类才能驾驭无法追踪的变量。
And that is what is actually different about this moment from any previous moment in the history of psychiatry. We don't need a better manual. We need to stop pretending the manual is the right kind of instrument. Because the instrument that can actually keep up with a fast-moving frontier is not a manual.
而临床医生自身工作的深度限制了他们这样做的能力。这包括他们那一年读了多少本书。他们注意力的质量。在面对导致失调的材料时保持调节的能力。那个说，我不处理这个问题，因为它只是，你是什么意思？那是一整类人。你不处理一整类人。这似乎是人口的很大一部分。也许你需要做一些工作。你会听到临床医生这样说。我只是不能和男人一起工作。我只是不能
That instrument is an informed human being. And the instrument is not just a human being in the trivial sense of needing somebody to deliver the protocol that's not an AI. The instrument is a human being in the strong sense that the active variables of the work are inherently untrackable. And only a human being can navigate untrackable variables.
和女人一起工作，因为他们总是，嗯，我的意思是，无论如何，那里有一些有问题的东西。即使是较小的问题，对于一个应该参与这个行业的人来说，这也是一个奇怪的陈述。你知道，有一种直觉来自于与数百名患者坐在一起，并对每个患者的需求产生了感觉。所有这些都无法提前测量，无法在手册中指定，无法通过简短的培训传达，而当结果产生时，所有这些加在一起就是产生结果的原因。而该装置花了40年时间假装这些变量不重要，因为它们无法测量。而这种假装产生了一代
And the depth of the clinician's own work on themselves limits their ability to do this. And that includes how many books they've read that year. The quality of their attention. The capacity to stay regulated in the face of dysregulating material. The one who says, I don't work with this issue because it just, what do you mean? That's an entire, like, gender of people. You don't work with a whole gender of people. That seems like a lot of the population. Maybe you need to do some work. You'll hear clinicians say that. I just can't work with men. I just can't
临床医生，他们没有被允许发展重要的变量，因为培训计划忙于在可以测量的变量上培训他们。结果是，重要的变量在有资质的劳动力中逐年变弱。而该装置一直在为保真度得分的提高而自我祝贺，而实际的护理质量指标，正如CBT中的复制危机向我们展示的那样，一直在变差。我们编造了一个我们正在变好的新数字。这只是不是有多少患者正在变好。
work with women because they always, well, I mean, anyway, there's some problematic stuff there. Even when it's smaller issues, that's a strange statement from somebody who's supposed to be participating in this industry. You know, there's an intuition that comes from having sat with hundreds of patients and developed a felt sense for what each patient needs. And none of these can be measured in advance, none can be specified in a manual, none can be transmitted through a brief training, and all of them together are what produces outcomes when outcomes get produced. And the apparatus has spent 40 years pretending that these variables do not matter because they cannot be measured. And the pretense has produced a generation
科学指出了任何标准化装置的局限性，随之而来的问题是，如果没有装置能跟上，我们该怎么办？唯一的答案，我的意思是，诚实的答案，是一个训练有素、好奇、具有整合能力且受过监督的临床医生，拥有时间、自主权以及摆脱官僚机构和数字的自由，去真正思考他们面前的患者。而临床医生是捕捉前沿的工具。不是因为临床医生有魔力，而是因为临床医生是整个诊断系统中唯一能跨越所有这些层和语境阅读的人，
of clinicians who have not been allowed to develop the variables that matter because the training programs were busy training them on the variables that could be measured. And the result is that the variables that matter have been getting weaker in the credentialed workforce year over year. And the apparatus has been congratulating itself for the improvement and fidelity scores, while the actual quality of care metrics, like the replication crisis in CBT shows us, have been getting worse. We made up a new number that we're getting better at. It's just not how many patients are getting better.
以及数字之间的空间，并根据特定患者的具体历史实时权衡它们，并在脑海中持有维度概况，同时结合呈现症状的网络，在会话中期注意到自主状态的变化，整合工作、反应、炎症和依恋，以及所有的历史与文化象征语境，与即时的行为模式，并产生随着新证据出现而逐次更新的临床形成。如果你想说，是的，但谁能做到这一点？那些激励结构和装置应该再次吸引到
And the science is pointing at the limits of any standardized apparatus, And the question that follows is, if no apparatus can keep up, what do we do? And the only answer, I mean, honest answer, is a well-trained, curious, integratively capable, and supervised clinician with the time and the autonomy and the freedom from the bureaucracy and the freedom from the numbers to actually think about the patient in front of them. And the clinician is the instrument that catches the frontier. Not because the clinician is magic, but because the clinician is the only thing in the entire diagnostic system that can read across all of these layers and context
心理治疗中工作的人。嗯，那是不合理的。为什么？如果你想让任何事情改变，你最好走出去让它变得合理。因为没有系统，没有指标，没有评估。而且没有什么东西不把人踢出去并吸引看起来像教育系统的错误类型的人。他们可以告诉你一些能让你做到的事情。
and space between numbers and wait them in real time against the specific patient's specific history and hold the dimensional profile in their head alongside the network of presenting symptoms notice when the autonomic states shift mid-session integrate the work the reactions and inflammations and attachments and all of the history with the cultural symbolic context with the the immediate behavioral pattern and produce working clinical formation, formulations that update session to session as new evidence comes in. And if you want to say, yeah, but who can do that? The kind of people who the incentive structures and the apparatus should be pulling in
临床医生是工具，因为临床医生是系统中唯一能同时持有所有这些东西并看穿它们的人。而这正是该装置40年来一直在积极反对的事情。该装置一直试图使临床医生可替代。那个词很重要，可替代，可互换，可替换。该装置希望任何临床医生都可以被任何其他临床医生替代。我们如何找出他们所做的重要事情，以便我们能让任何人做它？因为这就是使计费基础设施运作的原因，这就是使保险小组运作的原因，这就是使认证途径运作的原因。
to work in psychotherapy again. Well, that's not reasonable. Why? You better go out there and make it reasonable if you want anything to change. because there's not a system and there's not a metric and there's not an assessment. And there's not something that doesn't kick people out and attracts the wrong kind of person that looks like an educational system. They can tell you something that can make you do that.
但比这更重要的是，它使你对这些事情的信念运作。与它不运作的证据相反。而这就是使算法最终取代临床医生成为可能的原因。该装置花了40年时间系统地使临床角色去技能化，缩小临床医生被允许知道的内容，限制临床医生被允许做的事情，羞辱和评判任何知道他们不应该知道的任何事情的临床医生，那是禁忌知识，黑魔法。
The clinician is the instrument because the clinician is the only thing in the system that can hold all of those things at once and see through them. And this is what the apparatus has been actively working against for 40 years. The apparatus has been trying to make the clinician fungible. That word matters, fungible, interchangeable, replaceable. The apparatus wants any clinician to be substitutable for any other clinician. How do we just find out the important thing that they did so that we can make anyone do it? Because that is what makes the billing infrastructure work, and that is what makes the insurance panels work, and that is what makes the credentialing pathways work.
而那种禁忌知识只是哈佛教授在其他与心理学相关的领域发表的东西，我会指出。将临床接触转化为可以被任何东西复制的程序。而结束整个讨论的问题是，这是怎么被允许发生的？一个产生了一代能看到什么是错的、能说出什么是错的、拥有说明什么是错的证据基础的临床医生的领域，怎么会无法改变什么是错的？答案不是该领域很愚蠢。
But more importantly than that, it is what makes your faith in those things work. contrary to the evidence that it doesn't. And that is what makes the eventual replacement of the clinician by the algorithm possible. And the apparatus has spent 40 years systematically deskilling the clinical role, narrowing what the clinician is allowed to know, restricting what the clinician is allowed to do, shaming and judging any clinicians that know anything that they're not supposed to, that it's the forbidden knowledge, the black magic.
答案是临床医生是同谋。答案是结构性的，它与美国精神病学在文化中的定位方式，以及它建立社会盔甲的方式，以及它将复杂性作为盾牌，将对数字的崇拜作为这堵墙的方式有关。而问责制只是一种总是向下流动的东西，从机构流向临床医生，从薪水最高的人流向薪水最低的人，从来不是反过来的。这就是下一集。这就是第9集的内容。
Which that forbidden knowledge is just the things that Harvard professors are publishing in other fields that are related to psychology, I'll point out. To convert the clinical encounter into a procedure that can be replicated by anything. And the question that closes this whole discussion is, how was that allowed to happen? How does a field that produces a generation of clinicians who can see what is wrong, who can name what is wrong, who have the evidence base that says what is wrong, fail to change, what is wrong? And the answer is not that the field is stupid.
在第一集中，我说心理学是美国的眼睛，是我们学会看待自己的装置。而且我们在这一点上正在教其他国家，或者至少通过我们的眼睛影响他们看待自己的方式。我们把它放进了他们的脑子里。而我们用来描述内心生活的镜头就是我正在谈论的这些东西。我甚至无法摆脱我可能同意或不同意的词汇来讨论这些事情，因为它们是我们拥有的词汇。
The answer is that the clinicians are complicit. The answer is structural, and it has to do with the way that American psychiatry has positioned itself in the culture, and the way that it has built its sociological armor, and the way that it uses complexity as a shield, and reverence to numbers as this wall. And accountability is something that only ever flows downhill, from the institution towards the clinician, from the highest paid people to the least paid people, and never the other way around. And this is the next episode. This is what episode 9 will be about.
而且，你知道，我们无法看到镜头，因为我们总是透过它看。每次我们尝试检查心理学时，我们都使用心理学给我们的概念。这就是我在第一集中所说的。我们使用诊断思维来批评DSM。我们使用治疗语言来质疑治疗。检查的装置正在进行检查。而这个系列一直试图走出那个陷阱，不是通过拒绝心理学，你知道，我在开始时说过，
In the first episode, I said that psychology is America's eye and is the apparatus through which we have learned to see ourselves. And we are teaching other countries at this point, or at least influencing the way that they see themselves through our eye. We've put it in their head. And the lens that we use to describe our inner life is this stuff that I'm talking about. I can't even get away from the words that I may or may not agree with in order to discuss these things because they're the words that we have.
你知道，那样做会很疯狂。而是通过追踪该装置是如何形成的，以便我们可以将其视为一个历史对象，而不是上帝传下来的、事情可能永远如此的永恒现实。但要诚实地面对这一举措的局限性。你知道，走出该装置并不能给你一个来自虚无的视角。它给你一个来自另一个装置的视角，这就是为什么那些从这里跳船进入，你知道，某种狂野的男性权利Instagram或新时代的东西
And, you know, we cannot see the lens because we're always looking through it. Every time we try and examine psychology, we use the concepts that psychology gave us. That's what I said in the first episode. We critique the DSM using diagnostic thinking. And we question therapy using therapeutic language. The apparatus of examination is doing the examining. And this series has been an attempt to get outside of that trap, not by rejecting psychology, which, you know, I said in the beginning would be,
或者好吧，一切都没有意义，伙计，诊断不是真的，我的意思是，这就像说类别不是真的，什么类别，哪里
you know, crazy to do. But by tracing the history of how the apparatus came to be so that we can see it as a historical object rather than this eternal feature of reality that was handed down by God and the only way that things could ever be. But be honest about the limitations of that move. You know, stepping outside the apparatus does not give you a view from nowhere. It gives you a view from another apparatus, which is why the people who jump ship from this into, you know, kind of wild men's rights Instagram or new age stuff
有时诊断是适用的，我的意思是这个播客是一个装置，博客文章是一个装置，我正在写的书是，你知道，希望不会是，我写它是为了抵制
or well everything means nothing man and diagnosis isn't real I mean that's like saying categories aren't real what categories where
或者说，伙计，一切都没有意义，诊断也不是真实的。我的意思是，这就像在说分类不是真实的，什么分类，在哪里？
sometimes diagnosis is applicable I mean this podcast is an apparatus the blog post is an apparatus the book that I'm writing is you know will hopefully not be I wrote it to resist
有时诊断是适用的。我的意思是，这个播客是一个工具，博客文章是一个工具，我正在写的书，你知道，希望不会是（工具），我写它是为了抵制这种倾向。
something like that but who knows you know every form of articulation is an apparatus because every form of articulation has rules and the rules shape what can be said
大概是这样，但谁知道呢？你知道，每一种表达形式都是一种装置，因为每一种表达形式都有规则，而这些规则塑造了什么可以被说出来。
and what cannot be said gets left out and what gets left out is still part of the truth. And the eye that cannot see itself in isolation can be seen by another eye. And this is the secret of psychology that the apparatus, you know, could not capture and never will. Healing happens in relationship because seeing happens in relationship. And this stuff is in most fundamental religious texts. You know, the spec that I cannot see in my own eye, or the spec that I see in your eye is caused by the blog that I cannot see in my own. You know, you can't find your own blind spot. You need someone else's eyes for that.
而那些不能被说出来的就被遗漏了，但被遗漏的部分依然是真相的一部分。那只无法独自看见自己的眼睛，可以被另一只眼睛看见。这就是心理学的秘密，是那个装置无法捕捉也永远无法捕捉到的。疗愈发生在关系之中，因为看见发生在关系之中。这些内容在大多数基础宗教文本中都有体现。你知道，我眼中看不见的刺，或者我在你眼中看到的刺，其实是因为我眼中看不见的梁木。你知道，你无法发现自己的盲点。你需要别人的眼睛来帮你看到。
And the other person cannot find their own blind spot either. In systems and bureaucracies, don't provide the kind of accountability that accounts for the subjectivity that is required to check these things in a psychological entity. Psychological bureaucracy. They need yours. We need each other. And the work at its deepest is the mutual offering of sight. It is the communal activity of seeing what could not be seen alone. You know, the church at its best did this, and Union Halls in America,
而另一个人也无法发现他们自己的盲点。在系统和官僚机构中，它们无法提供那种能够解释心理实体中检查这些事物所需的各种主观性的问责制。心理官僚主义。他们需要你的，我们需要彼此。这项工作最深层的意义在于相互提供视野。这是一种共同的活动，去看见那些独自一人无法看见的东西。你知道，教会鼎盛时期曾做到过这一点，美国的工会大厅也是，
and the village council and the extended family, and all of the other meaning-making load-bearing structures of our world. The community in its moments of actually being a community does this. Psychology, when it has been good, has done this too, because of those times it was a community. and now it's more of a bureaucracy than a family. And the hour in the room when something works is the communal seeing in miniature between two people. I would like an apparatus, you know, a cold machine, that the ghost can warm up a little bit more.
还有村委会、大家庭，以及我们世界上所有其他承载意义的结构。社区在真正成为社区的时刻也会这样做。心理学在它表现良好时也曾做到过，因为那些时刻它是一个社区。而现在，它更像是一个官僚机构，而不是一个家庭。当事情奏效时，房间里的那一小时就是两个人之间微缩的共同看见。我想要一个装置，你知道，一个冰冷的机器，让那个幽灵能把它稍微暖热一点。
You know, it's tried to eliminate all the communal ways of seeing. It's tried to replace it with procedures that could be delivered interchangeably and providers that could be interchangeable and measured on interchangeable. and measured on interchangeable metrics and build on interchangeable codes. And it did all of that because it wanted a machine that it could build, that would do accountability and do self-awareness and do a system of growth and discovery in place of the human. And that project failed. If this convinces you of nothing else,
你知道，它试图消除所有共同的观察方式。它试图用可以互换提供的程序、可以互换的提供者、以可互换的指标衡量并以可互换的代码计费的方式来取代它。它做了所有这些，因为它想要一台它能建造的机器，能够代替人类进行问责、自我意识以及成长和发现的系统。但那个项目失败了。如果这不能让你相信别的什么，
it should be that those things cannot be done bureaucratically. You know, the communal seeing cannot be eliminated. It just goes underground when you make it illegal. But it doesn't die. It waits. And while it waits, it does what it's always done, which is to lie in private practices and supervision groups and accidental conversations between trainees and elders
那它至少应该让你明白，这些事情是无法通过官僚手段完成的。你知道，共同的看见是无法被消除的。当你把它定为非法时，它只是转入地下。但它并没有死。它在等待。而在等待的过程中，它做着它一直以来都在做的事情，那就是存在于私人诊所、督导小组以及受训者和长辈之间偶然的对话中，
and the small daily moments in which one person looks at another person and accidentally tells the truth. because they forgot to act and they forgot what they weren't allowed to know. And the cold machine does not know how to see itself. So it builds bigger structures of measurement that look like seeing, but they're not seeing. And the warm ghost knows that seeing requires another eye. So it keeps finding the other eye in whatever crack the apparatus has not yet closed. And that is what the field is underneath everything that I've described.
以及那些一个人看着另一个人并偶然说出真相的日常小瞬间。因为他们忘记了表演，也忘记了他们不被允许知道什么。而那台冰冷的机器不知道如何审视自己。所以它构建了更大的衡量结构，看起来像是在观察，但那并不是真正的看见。而那个温暖的幽灵知道，看见需要另一只眼睛。所以它不断地在装置尚未封闭的任何缝隙中寻找那只眼睛。这就是我所描述的一切之下，这个领域的本质。
Two eyes in a room looking at each other. one able to see itself and both willing to see the other as old as humans that is not going away and it's not really winning either it's holding you know the questions remain what is consciousness what itself what is meaning what is healing what is the relationship between body and the mind and what does the mind call itself what does it mean whatever these aren't questions that are going to ever be answered definitively and they are not questions I think they can ever really be answered biologically. They are questions that we are going to live inside no matter where they come from. And that is what psychology in its best sense always has been.
房间里两只眼睛互相注视着。一只能够看见自己，而双方都愿意看见对方，这和人类一样古老，它不会消失，但也并没有真正获胜，它只是在坚持。你知道，问题依然存在：什么是意识？什么是自我？什么是意义？什么是疗愈？身体与心灵之间的关系是什么？心灵如何称呼自己？这意味着什么？无论如何，这些问题永远不会有确切的答案，而且我认为它们在生物学上也不可能真正得到解答。它们是我们无论来自何处都将生活在其中的问题。这就是心理学在最好意义上一直以来的样子。
Not a science that closes the questions. A practice that stays with them alongside the suffering person for as long as the staying is needed. And that is the right to be uncomputable that you have. The right not to be a gear in this thing or a bit of data to be sold. hold the right to withdraw from measurement, the right to defeat the apparatus, not the promise that the worm ghost will win, the right to be fundamentally more than the measurement can contain. Because you already are, whether or not you know it.
不是一门终结问题的科学。而是一种实践，它陪伴着受苦的人，只要这种陪伴是必要的，它就一直存在。这就是你拥有的不可计算的权利。不成为这个系统中的齿轮或被出售的数据片段的权利。拥有退出衡量的权利，击败装置的权利，这不是承诺温暖的幽灵会获胜，而是拥有从根本上超越衡量所能包含的内容的权利。因为无论你是否知道，你本身就已经超越了这些。
So don't forget, you know, to remain in the depth of what we are is an open question. And to be met by another open question in a room where neither of you knows the answer. And the not knowing is the practice and the practice is what we have. have and what we have is enough. And the apparatus cannot give you the right to that. The apparatus cannot revoke it either. It's already always, always will be always was yours. And the work at every scale, individual and collective is to live as if we already knew that. It requires the faith to do something as loud and as crazy as myself and a lot of other clinicians have done. Or we just say, hey, come on, wake up, this is it.
所以别忘了，你知道，保持在我们本质的深度中是一个开放的问题。并在一个房间里被另一个开放的问题所遇见，在那里你们俩都不知道答案。这种“不知道”就是实践，而实践就是我们所拥有的。我们所拥有的已经足够了。装置无法赋予你这种权利。装置也无法撤销它。它一直都是你的，永远都是，过去也是。而在每一个层面上，无论是个人还是集体，工作就是像我们已经知道这一点那样去生活。这需要信念去做一些像我和许多其他临床医生所做的那样响亮而疯狂的事情。或者我们只是说，嘿，来吧，醒醒，就是这样。
And isn't that kind of weird and isn't that kind of silly? And in the next episode, I'm going to turn from the question of what the science is pointing at to the question of why we are not allowed to act on it and what it has already told us. You know, why the field produced this evidence, and it's still structurally prevented from reorganizing around it, and why the apparatus persists when the people inside it can see exactly what is wrong with it. and why reverence is the social technology that protects captured institutions from reform in a completely secular and objective way, and what would have to change for the practice of sitting with another human being to survive the era that we are entering. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这难道不奇怪吗？这难道不愚蠢吗？在下一集中，我将从科学指向的问题转向为什么我们不被允许根据它采取行动，以及它已经告诉了我们什么。你知道，为什么这个领域产生了这些证据，却在结构上仍然被阻止围绕它进行重组，以及为什么当身处其中的人能清楚地看到它有什么问题时，这个装置依然存在。以及为什么敬畏是一种社会技术，它以一种完全世俗和客观的方式保护被俘获的机构免受改革，以及为了让与另一个人坐在一起的实践能够在我们进入的时代生存下来，需要改变什么。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。